now you can be yourself even more on
career mode where you can basically make
yourself as a character and then keep yo
[__] you look terrified there when you
[Music]
ready right what's happenin right the
you f ck my sponsor already right okay
here we go
right you wanna start right just Curie
ordinate with the career of what you can
actually do is you can create yourself
maybe you already created yourself as a
fighter but then you can continue and
you can earn your way to the UFC become
a real fighter within the UFC start to
promote your fight and win a ride like
Ruiz that's exactly what I'm saying we
don't want to be a world choke big Brian
what you call yourself the gorilla yeah
on that what kind of people would you be
fighting if you a super heavyweight you
have a heavyweight kin the luscus people
like that yeah people in the game you
can be fighting yeah you can make your
fighter better to get to a point where
controlling them welcome yeah and you
can you can banter the other guys off on
social media and it says literally here
in the read become the goat I didn't
know goats could compete in real-time
but yeah oh hey the gorilla from the
initial fight to the world fighting a
lion
- your first UFC bout your actions both
inside and outside the Octagon will
shape your career so I don't know what
kind of fighter you'd be on Twitter
would you tweet a lot would you be a
more mysterious I'm an actively sort of
mousy guy I like to get in their heads
twit them I'm gonna beat them to a pulp
yeah do you think you are the kind of
guy who gets in someone else's head and
yeah definitely because and then at the
same time when you get in the ring are
you mouthing off at the other guy oh
yeah I'm talking [__] 24/7 what I did
quite liked was your your taunts when
you did it you're one of the ones who
does the hole yeah I'm a torn yeah
you actually are a taunton mm yeah it's
quite sinister Center yeah yeah I'm
definitely that guy no matter what stage
you're at in your UFC career there's
always someone looking to make you make
their name by taking you out and that
sort of correlates with your you know in
the long term I tell you yeah I'm always
one paying for dinner is there anyone
that you would is there anyone that you
were worried could take you out like
with you faced Francis and garner would
you be worried about he's not much of a
gust honks I'm bigger and stronger than
him I think I'll take him
it's a no problem yeah it's the champion
sleep with me or Church he's a pain in
the ass yeah he might be the one the
last one but then I still think I'll get
the job done yeah I can actually a
fireman you know in real life him really
he's a fireman and on UFC heavyweight
champ in the States
literally he puts fires out under then
he goes and kick sauce so that's
actually really badass that's not badass
than their podcast yeah so is that
enough is that all religious oh yeah
let's just cut the bit out where you go
is that enough you can choose eight you
can choose from eight unique unique
training gyms each of which has its own
fighting discipline yeah have you
thought about which discipline you're
going to so there's like a specially I
want to be someone who is dangerous
everywhere punching and on the ground
okay so you know the interested says Jim
and loyalty can have its rewards but you
truly grow as a fighter for American
Kickboxing Academy
that's the kid Belasco's one I want to
fight like him well in this game you
actually got authentic UFC training
partners who actually trained with the
UFC
writers and then the interesting side is
sometimes you might have to change up
your gym if say one of your aspects is
weak or you want to go in a different
direction or if or if you fight someone
from the same gym then you might need to
get some different skills I feel like
they've really thought about what a real
fighter goes through and tried to bring
people as close as possible to that
experience it's as real as a kettle and
it is that's true actually and if you
want to get as more fully that check as
real and it believe me I don't think
people paying checks anymore but you're
not a minute yeah well if you if you do
want to get as rid of it gets then go to
the link in the description which links
you to the game I also there's a link to
the trailer somewhere down there thank
you very much to UFC 3 and EA for
sponsoring this this podcast is
sponsored by powered by EA as they say
powered by a year Oh quite like they say
my house is going to be powered by here
for the next time see you want to do is
true Jordy podcast Kira daya
thanks like oh my man no problem bit of
a weird one for me got a message of alan
shearer last week saying Kira died on
severe on your podcast the 15 year old
me right now was I yeah
and you went Alan stop trolling well
with this book I have to do a lot of
publicity and I was a bit apprehensive
of going back up to the Northeast
like you say they've got mixed reactions
back up there and I'd seen the podcast
and I see that the base that you touch
so I said to my publicist for the book I
said I need to to do this podcast so
obviously I text ow
and said can you have a word and here we
are unbelievable but I must say I hadn't
seen the rants that you made against me
and Craig so then after I said this year
I've see a few and when you start
calling him a little dwarf elf and
caning him or even get this should be
interesting but in the day this is what
breaks my heart I love watching creep
bother me I love watching new player
like we aren't the best team am i I
actually prefer the Bobby team at the
Keoghan team I thought it was much more
fun to watch more organized even if it
was still the Wild West
so I guess we'll start with that mm-hmm
the thing that hurts is when we see you
on the debate and actually I've got a
I've got actual quote from another fun
because after the EE centers ass I've
got Kyra and I on the podcast any
questions let us know and I thought you
know yes this is what a lot of New
Castle fans have said and he sort of
summed it up yeah
after being selfish by Newcastle United
and worshiped by the funds why did he
[__] all over us in the tibia
unrealistic my Aussie said because when
you said that we thought were a chunk
into the club that really pissed a lot
of Newcastle fans off consider would
being relegated twice in the last ten
years I stick by that I think that with
your fan base and the support that you
give to the team I think that you
deserve well maybe it's because I think
that you deserve to be not a relegation
teamfighting and when I was there as a
plan we having successful when we came
fifth that season and didn't make the
Champions League
we were classed as failures that season
and that's the that's the that's the
reality of the of the situation so when
I was on the bait debate and saying that
maybe it was harsh on the fans because
like you said you have been relegated in
but maybe it's me as well because I
think Newcastle or mourning or just our
way we're happy to be in the Premier
League and like I said I do think if you
stay up this season and veneers and
stuff happen I do think your
expectations will be that I we can
challenge for European that's the next
step there's a difference between hope
and expectation I think everyone hopes
for them and especially the manager like
Benitez but I think I agree with what
you're saying about what it was like
when you were there I remember I
remember meself when we didn't qualify
I remember thinkin foxy like actually
finally I had a platform to make videos
just generally the fact that Bobby
Robson was let go for that as a failure
is insane
looking back at it it was it was the
dumbest thing that ever happened in the
whole of the Premier League history do
you think you should have made Champions
League that season hmm
I had a lot of injury problems that
season I think ray got his injury
problems the complacency kicked in as
well this is easy with Chambliss League
so you a story especially we have so
many young immature players you kind of
take your eye off the ball definitely
took our eye off the ball even with when
we had the Champions League qualifier I
think we won the first leg one nil away
I think us as players for what we just
had to turn up at st. James's Park we'd
win that game easily I think Freddie and
all the directors had already booked
their flight to go to the South of
France for the Champions League draw oh
so again maybe we took it all for
granted and fought this was just going
to be just ongoing yeah for the record
on me like I appreciate what it was like
when you were there and it was the
expectations were silly and we have been
spoiled at the time and I think every
Newcastle fan looks back at that with
fond memories for that reason but now if
New Castle's up like a real bad place
for football atmosphere like we
sometimes running to cheer the team on
but it's like it feels like the life of
the club is just being strangled out by
Mike Ashley and Champions League isn't
even in the minds of any funny it's like
we've got no hope of anything like just
staying in the Premier League until
someone buys us off Mike Ashley is
actually all
hoping for like there's that's the hope
not not even the expectation I think the
hope when dos years ago say maybe that's
maybe that's my era and I'd be the first
to put my hands up because I haven't
been back to Nuuk I've been back to
newcast twice I think in that all the
times that I've left so I'm just going
on probably the expectational this is a
player that when you went back I was all
good to exit actually cuz that was my
sister and my sister my missus his
birthday so we went up there for a week
Ankush she'd ever been up there for a
while so we went up there to see some
old friends she said she what to go to
the Metro Center I was absolutely
dreading it just walking down but
because people just and plus people talk
about them it like the Trafford Centre
in the Metro Center and conocía yes some
mates at once in life so I put my
baseball cap worn and lawful but the
love I got was it was surprising the yet
the the general who quieter got is we
wish we had players like you should
still kind of thing which was in a way
was quite lilies in rewardin if you know
I mean because I I did leave in a kind
of business sour kinda way it was a [__]
I'll always remember it was we played
Watford in the Glenn Roeder just been
sacked and Nigel Pearson was caretaker
manager we played Watford away and I
don't want to sound big edit than that
but we were Bartman and League that
season I missed the first few months of
that season and I came back into the
team I think the first game I scored
against arsh normal way and me over
Febby Martens and Scott Parker that
season kept the team up at
people might disagree and I'll go on and
limb and say that and it got to the
stage we played reading away towards the
end of the season and we were now going
on the bus to the game and Glenn Roeder
caused me down to the bus and he's he
says I want you to be captain today and
obviously because of what happened with
the captain's armband before I was like
I didn't really want to do it but he was
saying look you've you've been brilliant
for me this season that and I think it
would be a great honor for you and for
myself and I took the captain's armband
it was Michael Owen's first game back
from his crew shirt as well if you can
remember but it was read in a way and we
lost again we didn't play very well and
I can dick that I am I pick up the
Chronicle the next day or listen to the
free legends and get absolutely put how
dare he wear the captain's armband he
doesn't care about the club and lardy
lardy LA and I huh because I started to
mature and we will probably talk on a
bit where people say I give up this
attitude of I don't care and like I said
it was the last game of season then when
we played Watford and we were doing the
warm-up by the away fans you know the
away fans always takes over the ground
and they sawed the fan song individual
songs for every player except for me and
Stephen Carr anything I've had my few
scrapes in the past and done my things
and listen I'm not saying I should be
worshipped the way ever but like I said
for what I did that season to try and
keep us up in the Premier League I
fought I love affairs over now maybe
they're sick and tired of me I'm sick
and tired of them now so I had in my
mind that this is my last season so I'm
finished the last game of season I met
up with England obviously Sam Allardyce
had been named England manager I'm the
England in Newcastle manager and he
comes to the Lowry stand in the Larry
with the England team he comes to speak
to me Kamiya Michael Owen and each
saundra Gerdes points come across he was
obviously was so advanced before the
technology in sport science so I thought
I'd give him a go so my whole yeah I'll
come back to Newcastle and then when
pre-season come we play the Carla's the
Hartley pulls of the world and we're
paying Carlo and I remember coming off
the bus and some fan sits die you
[__] dick or something like that you
prick [__] off home or something and
after the game the Sam disappears and me
and Nigel Pearson are left in the thing
and I just kind of like kind of broke
down and you said you know enough is
enough for when I go I and then the rest
is history
that's mud that that one fun yeah that
was just such a yeah can swear you that
much yep obviously you kind of Mitch I
mean to put like he's on put the meal
now of the coffin you I was like
wherever I do how successful I am from
now because there were so many times I'm
running back over but it then came to
the stage whenever you had a bad game or
you that girls are gonna sue on the
first one they'll grown up and listen
again I'm not saying aside just because
because of all the cops are bad they had
every right to feel that way but I felt
I was always playing a losing battle
that I had to perform unbelievable every
game because if you drop off at one bit
then under fall though when I read a bit
of your book and I want I'm assuming
right hmm my impression was like most
Newcastle fans impression of you you've
been given all the [__] talent in the
world you didn't make the most of it and
you're a bit of a nob and that was
what's fair enough you know in the in
your prime especially sure and the
amount of stories about you in Newcastle
you are like the king of bling like
everything that the Razzie in the house
of my day if if I said to any journalist
I've got Karen Dyer coming on everyone
some stories about him yeah like I guess
for today's generation or watching like
whatever people think Raheem Sterling
gets a hard right now you yours with
times 10 but you did bring a lot of it
on yourself I understand that you are a
bit of a victim because in your mind at
some point along the way you were like
I've changed now I've grown up but
because you changed in your mind doesn't
mean everyone else's perception of you
have changed as well and and you turn
the corner and you're like actually I'm
gonna book me ideas up now people like
you're still the same block just because
you've changed doesn't mean everything
you did you didn't already you didn't
also do do you feel a bit trapped by
that those that must feel quite
frustrating yeah I do I think just going
on the jungle on the celebrity when I
came at the jungle the amount of
positive press I had where I think a
touch it on the book where one of the
first texts I got was from Jonathan wood
gay and he was like all my mates what
you're an absolute dick and I can't
believe what a decent guy you actually
are there and yeah yes I bought most of
it on myself because the king of bling
which I don't regret it's finally now
that I was the king of bling with the
earrings you heard the story of me
leaving earrings in the thing I don't
know own a watch now
I don't I I just think what were you
just sold on my jury in that I just I
just become mature what I don't need
they need it fifty thousand pounds
yeah just like bad the time and I
touched and I came from poverty and a
lot of football has come from poverty
and you get the money and you get the
fame and listen I could drop down debt
tomorrow so I would have a good time and
so I don't regret I've been the king of
bling it was spending my money and thing
and by my friends watches by my family
watches because these people are never
going to be in a position or we ever
fought you know like to enjoy ourselves
so I don't regret that but again I was
just
an immature kid there's one scene that
come across me when I'm reading your
book I'm not and actually some of the
interviews I watch with you everyone
thought you were this full of yourself
Lube a confident guy especially with all
the stories of Newcastle but actually
you are quite an insecure person like of
course I think I think obviously what
happened to me was as a kid I had to
have a sense of bravado so when I went
Joey bar and got Peter K in at QPR and I
sat down I broke down and he can you
explain that because we're sort of
jumping right now but I guess that I
sort of give a lot of context to how
your life sort of began and that
difficult so yeah ant to see you're with
this psychiatrist in QPR yeah
and that's Julie Barton's recommendation
so the funny thing about this the I
everyone loves Joey in his way so
basically Peter Kay came in and it
wasn't to see individuals it was because
Joey was having a ran at the coach and
stuff in Neil Warnock so Peter cave was
brought in is a lot of evidence he okay
was brought in his like a Passover I
like to write someone in between so
basically us as players would go in and
tell him what we fought about the
manager and the coach and staff and then
the manager in the coaches staff would
speak to PK and then he'd kind of try
and sort it because Joey are the
training ground [__] training [__] this
is [__] which listen Joe he's a very
honest person if he demands that's just
the way he is in life so uh so yeah so
Peter key what Peter K wasn't there for
individuals and it we just got to the
stage that just hearing him in these
meetings I I liked what he had to say
so I'm around this same time as while my
mum and my ex or the mother of three of
my boys she they were four I was
depressed but they forced the press
through my injuries so I'm they got to
the stage that Peter was around the the
club for a while and so he said
people could see him individually so I
went to him to talk about depression I'm
saying that people are worried about me
because my whole prime has been taken
and so is it getting we were just in
general like this and he was basically
saying he doesn't think I'm depressed
from injuries and there's more to it and
you know he's probing and probing and
then yeah it just came flooding out and
I told him about the child abuse and and
then when he started making me realize
and he's just like wow where is I always
thought I was stubborn and it wasn't so
much so I was stubborn it was just like
so I'd fall out with you like you'd
bring me a diet coke and I wanted a coke
and you're like and I'd like I'd fall
out with people over that like you're
disrespecting me so he was saying
because I was disrespected when I was a
ten-year-old I have vowed don't know
that were in my psyche that I will never
be disrespected again I will never show
vulnerability again and then when you go
through what has happened in your career
which managers teammates players yeah I
just put this whole barrier around me
this whole bravado yeah and it formed my
life but again I think I touched when I
did the interview in there thing I don't
want people to think that I'm using
child abuse as an excuse for some of the
decision of the decisions like me fallen
out with manager all right if I felt
disrespected manager I'll [__] I'm
not having it because I couldn't show
vulnerability and stuff so some of that
it's true but like you said for things
like iron a par and
being sent home from my buyer the libo
you fight that's got nothing to do which
solace I'm not using that as excuse but
it was scary to realize how much of my
life it did affect in the bravado in the
this like superhero semen I'm not yeah
kind of thing so I've come on such come
on such since I've had the help because
like even crying when I cried in the
jungle and that that would never have
happened
if I went had that advice no way would I
show that Robert Vaughn durability so
I've cried in public before okay so you
never mentally drawn a line had you sort
of buried that experience or what what
what was because a lot of people go well
it must be this did you ever draw that
line so basically when it happened I I
kept our sequel for twenty years I may
have told one friend here and there but
I never went into details of what
happened to me
I did in the book and I thought I just
thought I'd overcome it you know I mean
I just fought an overcomer all on my own
I don't think about it no more it's
locked away but I didn't realise that it
affected me in other things like for my
for instance my oldest boy Kai's seventy
now but when he was eleven twelve and
I've never hit my kids never never will
I'm not that kind of parent to dissing
balloon but he's a sensitive kid he's a
bit like me I am sensitive even though I
bought on this proviso so am it's crazy
so every time he said wait if he'd fall
over and he just got little grazing he's
crying
I would snap like don't cry man up and
and like you could see like family
members and like fingers like oh he's
hard on him and it gots a stage when my
ex was saying to me like you're proper
hard on him and I was like no I'm not
and it just needs that I didn't I just
for that was normal behavior and again
it was Peter case and more 11 or 12 you
and you see brought and you just don't
want him to be
taken advantage of him unis just right
the hardener mom yeah and like so the
amount of relationships and friendships
and stuff it affected it was proper and
I didn't see this I just thought that
was just who I am my thing but thank God
for Peter guy do you think I was part of
the generation you were part of that you
guys were less it was sort of you were
on the cusp of like say you and just met
big Sam and he was bringing technology
into the game
social media wasn't even a thing was
your thing Sir Bobby was a bit of an
exception of a manager at that point
though what he was emotionally
intelligent I think I think I think also
the old school everyone is talking about
the old school regime and how we need to
bring it back and the kids need to be
doing all these jobs and they need to be
around the first team because academies
are separated from first team and I hear
all these debates but I think it has a
bit of a damaging effect and I'll tell
you there's a story in the book but I
think it's so when I was a youth team
and player hip switch and I was doing
really well and I'd have to train with
the first team I dreaded it and because
they were so hard school um so and the
way they talked to you you [__] [__]
and editor and there was one up I can't
I wasn't allowed to name him because of
legal reasons in the book but there was
a senior player in switch at the time
and he was one of the main players and I
lonely six things I mean and I came in
train and I ripped him up in training
absolutely destroy a bus will you help
us to it so it would have been about 96
you can do yeah yeah and work out
yourself xenia yeah and I ripped him up
and already other senior players were
laughs a name so after the Train and
I've gone in to help the youth team
loads because we finished our jobs
earlier we could go home otherwise we
could be at the ground until 4 or 5
o'clock so how open the change room open
cleaning up the China and this players
come in he's just wearing a slip he's
completing makings were honestly
he comes in the middle of the thing in
his life and he starts training and you
think house he's trainable but all of a
sudden pisses dribbling down his legs is
this pissing in his lip and he's taking
a [__] any slip he takes off the slip
and froze it by my favorite splatters on
four he says clean that up you [__] he
little [__]
something applied do and this is all
because I did my job really like so so
after this incident and I mentioned abut
we go to Malaysia for the under-20 World
Cup and we were well behaved on that
trip and then we lose to Argentina in
the quarterfinals in Argentina red will
kill me everyone knows about our cameras
ready aim are in cambiaso playing in
their team and we were after the game we
lost we went to the hotel bar let loose
and I mean let loose in it it got to the
stage about midnight 1:00 o'clock all
pissed and someone thought it would be a
good idea if we all got a plastic bag
and took it in turns to [__] in this bag
and someone someone but this is just the
mindset and the mentality there's no
football was like this this is in the
under-20 England represent your country
so no so the goal during races when
we're in the fooling the thing but this
is under 20 so basically this bag gets
passed round by round and people are
dumping in it I didn't dump in the bag
but it wasn't because you were holding
it is because I didn't need a dump at
the time right yes so I'm not taking any
brownie points first so so yes so
basically this bags are thrown and then
one of the players goes and hangs it on
the manager our managers door Ted Powell
he was an FA coach she was our manager
and this bag was hung on his door we
don't know what happened to the bag I
don't know if someone an hour later
thought it was a bad idea removed the
bag or hotel founder or the manager
because there was never an inquest and I
and I say in the book like that sums up
everything that's wrong with English we
thought it was funny and banner but that
is everything what was wrong the
disrespect was that it was like maybe
six or something so yeah so my first
season in the team so is the 96-97
season that was so naughty know you're a
six there they go ahead and doing that
stuff so you think see I say in the I
say in the book could you imagine
racquel me or am i doing something like
that and then I'm saying does that go
from what we were kind of that was and
player sitting in front of me from the
coach as ban Aaron in that environment
is that in our mindset that this is the
invite this is the way we're going when
you got so it was like a vicious circle
and yeah you did when you when I raped
women when I show people the story and
you read about are going to details
you're thinking I wonder England have
struggled the way their bogus yeah
that's what the chapters called the bag
yeah yeah when I started reading that I
wasn't expecting that was gonna yeah but
we thought it was finding we didn't
think we would we didn't think it was
disrespectful are this is great banner
we can all wherever laugh at her but but
to put it on ER the manager of your
country's door and did not respect him
was that we did I the guy was a great it
was no disrespect meant to the manager
but even even though it's the biggest
disrespect ever yeah we're not thinking
that we're just fingernail funny what's
so cool about if switch your you're
progressing through the ranks did you
have any other encounters with this guy
who pissed you off pissed on the floor
no he was fine with me over there now
cuz every time in training after that I
just let him tackle me and let me get
his confidence and well she was quite
fragile did you think like looking back
at that do you see an older guy who's
got quite fragile
he's literally [__] himself it was
just I just think it was the way is the
you have to bear the younger your mental
that's the way like I used to have a
like a like a bum fluff of attached and
I used to just like [__] take a piss
on me so and if you like just brutal but
ladies just detainer I hate like I said
I'm a young lad and you want to play in
the first team you want to train in the
first team when I was like I don't want
to train with the first team I'd rather
stay with my youth team and be happier
but you just have to toughen up and in a
way it does toughen you up big it does
get you ready for the first thing
because when we're talking about keeping
the academy boys away from the first
thing what happens they're so fragile
now I'm coaching them I can't even give
them the hair try a hair dryer because
they'd cry that parents will come in
there would be bullying claims and so
they have to be ready for to go into the
first team environment where they're
gonna make mistakes and teammates are
gonna dig them out because I don't think
they're ready because they are so
fragile at the moment so but it's just
getting the balance because the way we
had it and the way their antics were
then it has a coach now hmm when someone
makes a big [__] in training how do
you deal with that after
again that I always say this and I do
want to go into that side of it
especially with Ipswich hopefully and
yes tactics are important then yes
players important in stuff but the
biggest thing I find is management
because I took on under Bobby Robson
he's bigger strength who's he's my
manager he didn't treat the same players
the same like Roy Keane came to it the
stories Roy Keane was manager hip switch
and it was just one way and he treated
every player a certain way and all
players are different all players of
things so even with my six things I've
tried to find out who can take a bit of
a dig who I need to put an arm around so
again if it depends who makes the
mistakes if I know someone who can take
it and Digger I'd dig him out in a
subtle way I mean so because that's very
important so you you smashed it at
Ipswich Newcastle come :
what was it like getting that move to
Newcastle I'm shocked because again
Leeds and Arsenal is the two big I
thought they was in the paper all the
time Arsenal glazed the bid was gonna be
imminent I just got back from my well I
was on holiday and I had a / I had a
vice Bowl message from route Allah Harry
Redknapp as well which was I was buzzing
showing on repeating it for my friends
and speak if I listened to this got root
on it so when so when I went into George
Bailey's office in he said Newcastle I
was a bit oh not not deflated or
anything was just oh like where does
that come from I because I thought he
was going to say you're going to Leeds
or leads or Arsenal so I'm basically I
didn't have no time to think George
Burley bases so we accepted a bid from
Newcastle arrangements they were gonna
meet you're at Stansted in two hours and
you're going to Newcastle so I literally
got my mate to chide me to Stansted on a
plane straight to meet Freddy Fletcher
on the tarmac took me straight in to
have a medical sign the forms and then
was on a plane to Holland to meet the
first
Scott so I didn't even have time to
process or anything but when I did and
you think about it that two massive
cellar points were routed up because of
what he did achieved in the game and the
60-foot boom and obviously alan shearer
wasn't like when he first met those two
characters yeah in all kind of thing in
all just the presence this just they
don't have to say not and it's just the
respect they commanded and ironically
those two would end up in a bottle of
oil so I was gonna just come on to that
but literally I I go to pre meet up in
Holland on the Friday and under the
Saturday I knew that something worked
quite right just the way route hood it
would talk about any means and because
he pulled a meet one meeting straight
from Holland we went to Scotland and we
had a meeting there was me Duncan
Ferguson Gary Speed and that's when he
bought gomar and Dumas Marcelino we're
all in this meeting Shearer is not in it
the way he was talking was that Shearer
wasn't going to be in the startin team
and so I'm thinking what the hell's
going on here kind of things so I'm yeah
I didn't really get time to protect
process the move and I had no regrets
about it because yeah
that was the best period of my life with
regards to football a hundred percent
but yeah that whole dynamic of Shearer
and her little bit gist and people say
it was a ego bout and a battle of wills
and maybe it was with rude but I don't
think it was without at all and even
with that even with the Derby game and
it's a good story about that as well as
that he didn't even pull our side to
tell to tell him he wasn't playing
he basically John Carver gave out bibs
on the game so
I think the the star be game was on the
Wednesday I'll choose there was a
midweek game offical member and so the
day before in training he's given our
bibs to the reserve Saturday so you see
him giving up if Duncan's getting a bit
because he's regaining his fitness and
he's and he gave Alan a bib and you're
thinking wow and like know a man like
well I'm sure we'll get to it the right
wing with Bobby if I was England captain
and the best player the Premier League
ever sin and I was given a bib I would
have probably thrown the bib in route on
his face and walked off and got on my
car he puts on his bib he's so
professional I swear this is Alan
Shearer he puts on the bib you could
tell he's kind of it's kind of I don't
know is the word embarrassing there must
be a word is most at work I think
disrespect yeah I think he's been
disrespected he puts on the bib and so
we have the third the first team that
was playing against Sundin and then with
against the reserves and I thought sure
I was in the reserves reserves with
Duncan Ferguson and with this is the day
before and he's been disrespected and we
lose to the reserves something like
about six nil and Duncan scores for an
hour scores two and you think and you
think we're going into a darbian it's a
must swim but the whole the whole way
out our handed that situation was just
listen just know me is that would have
been completely different and and again
to counter that as well because everyone
talks about route it's pretty obvious at
the time that Shira didn't play I mean
she read in like route the way he was
doing the robbery situation of stuff so
if you're a manager and your jobs on the
line because it was a must-win game do
you put a player in that doesn't like
you
is he gonna fight too for now for you
so I can see where rude was coming from
but then to counter that again is that
it's a Darby Alger Geordie
every time he goes on the pitch
regardless of who's manager who's going
to give a hundred and ten percent so
yeah if Duncan and Shira were would have
started the game against under them we
were the one that came regardless of the
waiver in the condition sealer has evil
get in the one hundred percent so when
when I gain when I talk about man
management rude who not was one of the
best coaches I ever were when he put on
a session in these instructions and the
way he did it fantastic he was like he
was up there with one or two of the best
coaches I've ever had but he couldn't
get the mad management right again don't
know if I was a great player there was
times with Nick Costas s so he'd want
Nick Costas s to ping the ball out or
wing up right about that high drilled in
and then out to the other side and
Debbie's ass couldn't physically do it
so ruining it would like god I want you
to do this we've both fake like he
couldn't get his head round that players
couldn't do what he is asked in your
finger moves because you're a wall
priority year so the management side of
a rude just it didn't have down to a
tear now obviously it cost him unions
and then Bobby Robson was brought in
yeah and I must admit I'm having this
impression of who you are when I seen
you get the news I watched it on YouTube
at the time was uploaded when you were
playing for West Ham I always had this
impression of like you were the one who
shafted Bobby and really that's how it's
painted in Newcastle especially like he
was let down but like key retire I was
the real person let him down more than
you only that's what people think
obviously reading a book I'm trying to
get in the full picture now
but when I seen you in tears when Bobby
passed away I thought [__] her like I
didn't I didn't expect my from him yeah
and that's when I thought or there's a
lot more of this was it an instant
connection between you and Sir Bobby
there was
obviously apes which because he was Apes
which the connection and I remember when
I was in Ipswich Town player we played
Italy in the under-20 ones and Bobby
Robson had had his first season at
Barcelona and he was he was then van
Gaal comes in he's given the upstairs
when I was some director of football
scout so he's come to the game because
Buffon and tightiy were playing and I
probably one of the best games I've ever
played we win one nil I score the winner
and I upstaged Tati in booth Roberto he
was a hell of a house especially then he
was basically our whole team talks that
wave was just talking about a tiny story
my Mike Kenny so we're in am sell for
France I take my mate to sell for France
with me and we were in sell for France
and now we're in this beach bar great
bar great great day so it's happening
during the day and we come out in the
afternoon and tought he was there and he
was in speedos obviously some are mates
pissed in that and tight he's like
waiting by this taxi rank of a few
friends and my mate once at axiom thinks
I use the one who gets the Tigers
obviously football is no he kind of
night to show the respect and I'm just
like what though what are you doing Rick
this is the greatest Italian player and
you were getting him to flag down
attacks my mate was oblivious so we
finally getting the texture
yeah so like we finally get in at a time
like sofa time you get in a taxi and we
make it's like being anyway what's that
toy right yeah you've you've just been
telling to get you a taxi so yeah
creditor begets like an attack see yeah
so yeah they're tight yeah you up stitch
taught you that must feel good looking
but booth fun no a sport against boo
from bigger yeah yeah so in the tunnel
after the game
Bobby's there and so obviously I'm at
cinema if I've never had a conversation
he comes up to me and he's asking about
a position he always used to talk about
he lives on Constitution he used to have
a house in Constitution Hill which I I
lived there now which is quite ironic as
well so am Kindred's birth so yeah any
you saying look the way you're going
I'll get you to Barcelona one day so
free 17 18 year old kid to here that was
fantastic and then obviously becomes
Newcastle managing we we do have it was
like a father-son relationship and
people from the outside if he looked at
it the way we had disagreements in front
of other players and that people could
see that was a disrespect and that but
it was just the relationship we we had
like he could I I could shower him like
leave me alone and dead Adair and people
don't want to help but it was never
personal was just the kind of father-son
kind of relationship we had and I love
that them story I read in the book about
I think was the bus at us one I think
that's that's challenged some tactics or
coach or something cuz a couple of great
stories as so so when I'm talking about
Bobby is the best mmm and damn I was
talking about man Brandon and when I say
I don't use a lot of the things when I
was younger as excuses so basically we
played Bradford
then one of Bob see Bobby's first season
we're winning one new at half time but
it was a crap performance that Crowley
getting on us and Christian Perseus he
struggled when he was a Newcastle player
and the fans were getting on his back in
particular so he come in at halftime
and Mick wodsworth was the gaffer's
assistant at the time and he's
absolutely hammer and Christian
proceedures can soar on him and ours
crap that game and speedo is crap again
always senior players was just as bad
and he's gone cheating to precede us so
that's where the vulnerability picking
on a young kind of thing so I'm like
looking around waiting for someone to
say silence and I'm like basically I so
I say - Christian - Mick you're a prick
like leave the kid alone he's he's
struggling a man our time you only pick
on him you don't say anything to [__] an
hour now you [__] [__] house like
proper going into it I've lost it now
and he's like how dare you show me some
respect my say like show you respect you
show him some respect like you was pick
on the young lad you always pick on the
wall or you always pick on Shola grow
some [__] balls and [__] pick on
some of the senior players anyway it's
going back for is he's gonna then
Bobby's gone shut your mouth to me like
Bobby went so now it's hard for us to
imagine Bobby or not because he know you
anyway now dare you talk to my stuff
like that show some respect
so now I've started crying we're more of
anger and frustration because he's
picking on young so I'm like a little
spoiled brat now I'm not playing no more
I want to go I'm going to go and see my
mommy and I've literally took off my top
my boots my shorts said I'm not playing
and I've gone to go and get a shower
it's a gallery speed because al was our
captain but Gary Speed was our real
captain and the way I mean that is that
for us younger players al was more I was
more of a captain because of what he
does on the football pitch you figure
the leader but off the pitch he it's not
like he was a captain checking it but
Gary speed would so you had clicks you
had the brat pack you had the older lads
you had the following more approachable
and Island
yes because when we interviewed Allen
one of the fans of the show who happens
to be celebrity Robbie Williams yeah
message me and said he'd make a very
good gangster
I mean I'm intimidated by many people
but I can sort of understand how someone
would get intimidated by Allen
especially if you're playing in a team
and you're looking up them whereas was
Gary more for people guess and course he
would he Gary you could fit Gary in
anyone in him clicks and it beat the
life and soul of the group so he could
come with the brat pack for a night out
perfect he could go with the senior
player you go with the foreigners he can
go so-so didn't surprise me when this
argument kicked off and gone a shark
speedos coming in said look get your
boots on dead editor no no I'm still
sniffling away and then the gaffer comes
in and says to Gary
Gow so I'm thinking here we go but
because of that defense that stubborn
something and I am not backing down if
he start and he goes softly spoken he
went I love what you did son thinking so
straightaway my anger starts to ever and
you win you are totally right
I absolutely love that you protect the
young players that shows a real leader
in you and that but I can't be seen to
be disrespecting my quads worth because
he's my staff so I've got to show that
he's got power over you but I totally
understand so now I'm feeling a million
dollars at heart Bobby understands and
then he was like you've been the best
player in this even though I hadn't well
it wasn't
he was like you were brilliant first off
you're the best play we need you you're
gonna win this the game come on get your
boots back on obviously put my shirt
boots back on I end up scoring the
winner and I was just going to show like
when you talk about man manager Mick
wodsworth feels a million dollars
because the managers back tsys and I
feel a million dollars that bloody oh
the gaffer knew what I was doing and the
gaffer stopped the one-man revolt just
like that and there wasn't this this
Oasis okay this is us it's absolutely
genius and like I said when people talk
tactics and that just being able to get
players to get a hundred play to 200% of
them above and beyond and that's what
you do because if you look at our team
and I say the best way to the Bobby as a
manager and it's no disrespect to the
players I'm going to mention before we
signed Jonathan Woodgate we were in the
Champions League or always up there we
had a back for of Aaron Hughes or
Griffin who could play right back what
defense was [__] I'll say sooner than we
live here Bernard and we would come and
third and fourth if we don't a good
defense we would have won the [__]
list you know and the sales pack been
made so you mentioned it before actually
another one sort of Gary's speed it was
really nice to hear you speak about them
like that because obviously you just see
the man on the pitch IDO and realized
what how much goes on in season how much
he did for people what was it like for
you when you got the news he passed away
in such a tragic circumstance Wow
when we talk about Gary Speed as a
player first the season he goes and then
we get nothing it was the season we get
Nicky but James Milner Cliver
things started to go downward and a
downward spiral when he went and then
obviously Craig goes later on this
season that just goes to show what he
did for that change room and everything
and as a player and as as a leader I
think that was the beginning of the
demise I like the glue a lot yeah so
when he went I was like the beginning of
this my so when I obviously found the
news and it didn't really hit me but I
was so worried because I'm closest to
craig bellamy and craig bellamy it was
like craig bellamy second dad like i
said i've got the relationship with
Bobby that was how Craig was we have to
Welsh boys as well and Craig looked up
to him absolutely so I was dreading the
phone call I obviously thought that
Craig might have known and when Craig
always has I think Oh Craig was playing
on sky that day and
I never ring Craig because Craig is soap
fool everyone says obey Him is one of
the most professional people you'll ever
think so he very rarely takes calls so I
rang him about three or four times he
didn't pick up then he rings me and I
think he was on the bus on the way to
the game and I said have you heard the
news about speedo and he was like
wireless his he's committed suicide and
like Craig goes straight into no no you
know how rumors are Karen look how many
we did it and he goes in - no - no and
he was like look I'm gonna ring because
they've had the same PR woman Suzy and
he's like I need to ring her need to
ring her so yeah that was a tough phone
call and it was tough to thing but I'm
not gonna lie and people might saw me
for this but it got to the stage that it
was so a week or so after his death I
think or maybe a couple of weeks after I
think it was only a week after his death
so obviously her and Craig was playing
for Man City and they had a Liverpool in
the League Cup semi-final and so I went
to Anfield to see Craig and he got Gary
Space two sons invited Gary's dad and
Gary's two speeds inside the box and to
see their stream from bright these two
boys were honestly you would never the
strip while one was really quiet but
there was a thinke son was called edy
and he was just like how strong and how
he was it made me angry at Gary speed
like and it's tough like because I'm not
in his head by stirring and how could
you leave these two boys and I was
pissed off of him so I'd gone from
extremely hurt to so angry with him and
I was just because I see his two boys
and yeah that was tough but you know
think
logical son yeah and I think so cuz
because what's happened to me people
have taken their lives and I get that
but when this kids involved you know I
think how do you do that and so that's
what made me and seeing their bravery
and strength
I just so I had for about three weeks
like what the [__] you doing like how
could you do that but obviously as time
goes in listen you don't know what go in
people's heads impression is literally
exactly that it makes me so we are look
at depression it's it's like I don't
know when I was a kid I had an illness
where me blood cells were performing the
way they shouldn't do and I guess for
depression it makes you your brain think
things that shouldn't think and like
people would be better off without as
and all of this and it's very sorry yeah
it is because it makes people it is a
disease general I mean of course yeah
but I remember saying his sons on the
pitch with all of Mike and like you it
was it [__] filters with emotion and
so much respect for them as young men
like of course yeah I I couldn't it's
just so hard to explain how they were
how like I'm treating their dad died
like all like you and you said yourself
what a great mom like us as well
it's just does everything for everyone
every not the type of bloke who would
ever want to leave his sons without a
dad clearly not a sec you know I mean
but this is everything is don't lie even
everyone talks about whales and what
they did he laid the groundwork he's
done justice the man he was he oh yeah
just and again which pains me and listen
and the he had a bit of a tough going
with the crowd at some times it's true
at some changes
how can Gary speed like because when you
talk about leaving every inch of
yourself on the page every single time
yeah
what-what-what-what fernery was in how
many feel being a player played
alongside him because it seems that you
don't perceive yourself to be in that
sort of same style of player as he was
or Allen was or that's a stoic British
man who saw you know just guess that's
the old-fashioned the old-fashioned
football player how did you see yourself
compared to them what do you mean
playing with him what do you mean when
you when you're alongside them what kind
of play would you describe yourself as
because he was obviously a really suit
to his business very seriously wasn't
the flare player or the young promising
talent that many were I had most mostly
sick a success at Newcastle because of
him because he gave me the license to
just go and do what I would and he'd
he'd basically response a responsibility
and can you remember that time when we
played Liverpool it was an away game and
we go into each other's face and have a
little bit of a person match and there's
me pushing speed OFAC thinking he's
gonna kill you for the last 20 minutes
of the game is how am I gonna Galvez
because he will put your shot cause he
had a bullet so I'm again talking about
the man in that so I'm again he's a
senior pro and even though he's our
frustration Tony he did push me first
but by still I was telling the [__] off
you prick and that disrespected him and
I'm worried for my well-being and what's
gonna happen when we get into the change
room and after the game he comes
straight to me and goes I started up I'm
sorry and shrinking I the guy was just
just this is a senior pros the light
like and you got a little 20 21 22
year-old disrespect to you in a way even
even if and he was the one first one to
apologize in it and everything you think
what a man mmm-hmm one thing well I
think when you talk about him as a
player
it's funny because you were like
everyone talks now about schools Lamport
Gerald and that and I suppose schools
was on it he was very much his own
player nobody was ever like quite like
schools but Gerald and Lampard were
compared a lot but I remember back in
the day they were in your shadow as the
young players do other you were the one
that everyone had picked for greatness
you were a [__] great player in the
Champions League and you were really
good for Newcastle but why do you think
you never went down the way Lampard and
Jared have because I'm in the forward
from my book I got P Taylor to be Taylor
to do the forward in my book and he says
he's gone about and he says it's easy to
play the what if game and he's saying
that I should have played for a
Barcelona and I should be mentioned in
the same breath as them and I got when I
was on the pitch again it gets able to
up when I got a bit sometimes I get lay
but he doesn't care in that and I can
now say that I say in the book everyone
looks at James Moniz the epitome of hard
work dedication did it every time I play
for any club I had the most running and
again I had the most high intensity in
the game oh I was in the top three every
single time I was on the pitch does that
show someone who doesn't care if you
like me and when you're talking about
these players what happened to me is I
got so when I was on the pitch I gave
100% but the lead-up to a match or
training I cut corners if we just for
instance if we had a Saturday game
nomid we came in a Saturday game my
night would be Saturday night were out
Sunday night we go to Julie's Monday and
would be in the gay into Tiger Tiger
choose they would be another student
night so when you're thinking of top top
athletes to go to the next stage it
might be just naught point 5 percent
there might be no point 6 percent
when you're out Saturday Sunday Monday
Tuesday again people may say oh yes he
did no I didn't so if there was a club
rule in place where you weren't allowed
at 48 hours before a game we never broke
that for how British or whatever we were
there were some rules we abided - but
still if you're out for tennis and I'm
not talking going out and not drinking
we're doing 10 damn buca's than that so
did I for four more potential no and
thus I think because I got it all
horribly wrong off the pitch with my
dedication and my professionalism and it
again it pains me that when I went to
West Ham and I was mature and I was the
first run into training the last one to
leave to training
very rarely had a drink did everything
right
following the Gary speak I couldn't stay
fit you just think it's at Karma for
what you did a new custom yeah of course
what's the title again Oh too soon smart
too like yeah I like that I do as well
it's just because I love my boxing and
it was quite like Mike Tyson used then
and then he also says them everyone has
a plan until they get punched in the
face and I used that about when I break
my leg at Western that this is the prime
of my career and I'm ready to kick on
and live my life like a proper pro and I
never got the chance because of all the
injuries after that one of the things
that you said in the book was like we
talked about your night life and all and
I mean the stories about yeah and I
don't I want you to clear this one of
caught me because I've heard this in so
many different variations I think I know
oh yeah a 20 pound or a 50 pound or you
say that making it rain he's lighting it
on fire what the [__] did you do is
complete and I I've heard this story
about me burning 50 pound notes at first
it was I was burning 50 pound notes in
Ipswich and then it was I was burning 50
pound notes in Newcastle and the funny
thing about it is that the amount of
people who said they've witnessed this
this nightclub must be big Ernest in
James's Park
necessarily I'm telling you now and I
think you know from my book how honest
and how honest if I did I'd admit it I
don't uh pose in your eye or worse I
have never ever burnt money ever in my
life and the funny thing is like when
this goes out and you'll read the
comments I'll bet there'll be someone
not too long ago I was in a Rambo I
because I don't drink though I was in a
bar and this woman comes up to me and
she was like I you seem to really mature
cuz I was in there the night in the
colleague the club was called
Hollywood's inner light gotcha and I was
there that night when you burnt money on
our way
you liar why are you lying I've never
heard she was like oh I weren't there
but I was in the club that it's never
happened and you just think where does
it what I do I think I do know where it
come from because I heard this story
when I was a youth team player it was
being talked around their hips which and
there was a an established Premier
League player and then I go and tell my
mates we were in a bar and I was got oh
you gotta hear this story and the story
was that this player was trying to get
into a nightclub and the bouncer said
you ain't getting in here just because
you're a football I don't think I can't
think what you bloody blood and this
plant gets out money burns the money
assists bet you can't do this something
along them lines and the only way I
think this has happened is that it's
like the Chinese rich but someone tells
the story to someone else and by the
time again sir and from and then it ends
up me being the player and the thing is
at the time when I told this story I was
like I was a youth player in like 47
pound fifty a week and by the time this
door rumor was coming out in Ipswich I'm
thinking well how do I live with I just
generally don't NATO is the way it's
speak to people yes that's true so
because I know loud to all that's always
[__] to do so you like I've never
bought money but there'll be times where
I've had a poor game a phone come up to
me be I'm gonna go dude
you prick [__] go home and I'm like
mate leave me alone I'm with my mate
some of the thing and he's like don't
you tell me I [__] I pay I pay your
wages and I'll go
[__] me I didn't know your season ticket
cost free million quid along that just a
dick but in retaliation so yeah there's
been times where a fan will sing and I'd
give it large - what if because you're
hitting something a good light there and
that's fair but have you ever just where
nice not it's like I own the place just
cuz you know how you said that your
eagle was taken over at one point yeah I
think I touched on the Ayia Napa
question you know you didn't burn money
have you ever made it rain no no shame
really kinda hope you to place Ronnie
because one of my heroes now and I small
for what he does in the ring is fly
maewyn he has things on Mike's a train
and everything yeah yeah now I've never
done that but like you said I've I have
cash people off before and when you say
you Bowl around like you own the place
yeah I think a touch and own Ayia Napa
it was like the it was like that sold if
that was them but that was the the
height of it was like you you think
you're above the law
well the way people treat you like the
adulation it gives you a sense of
entitlement we were in people ruin their
best clothes we're come and sweaty with
Bo and sand all over the place straight
from the beach 15 of us being allowed
into a a bar me and woody having a beer
fight and like if things people get
splat with beer and we're not caring in
the world and you just look at it now I
need you think what the [__] will be
thinking but and I touch own because
people say because I think it's British
mania in general on holidays when they
go aboard but because we were
professional footballers I think we were
even worse if you know I mean so
British men going off at these holidays
and expect certain things and whatever
but we were he just took it to her and
again yeah when we went to Baja there
was kind of thing that we run the gaff
kind of thing without the burn of money
and stuff but you know that look at us
we're playing in the Champions League
and yeah probably would have been worse
to be fair that was one thing I've
actually never be in that night if for
say enjoying being young and [__]
richer I don't think you should be good
shot a lot and you didn't have social
media then so you could get away a bit
more as well now you would have been
[__] to get your camcorder out at one
point anyway lumps in real and you touch
on that what was it like when you
realize that [__] was going down with
the left because it seemed to freak you
out of it in the book where you're like
[__] me like I'm because then the
newspapers coming out saying player in
gang rape and all of that and it's yes
when I come home again when you're
talking about entitlement and the way
you are so I came home from iron Apple
and like the land at Thursday morning
met my friends in a bar on all day at
firs Day Afternoon and one of my friends
get into a scuffle
look at me seven stone went through car
fryer finds there's me at the front who
would the [__] you did get smashed in my
I get split open I go to hospital I'm
always in a pretty bad way after by what
I test in the morning everything so when
I'm at the hospital my mum rings me and
says the press are outside something and
I'll [__] it the press got older this
that quick so anyway of snuck in and
around the back and they were there all
day until like Saturday night kept
knocking on door can we get quote so I'm
not know so then my mum goes and gets a
paper and the Sunday something and it's
going to be about a fighting and you
finish like English stars in video sex
tape and yeah and my mom comes in throws
the paper me you're an embarrassment and
and I'm like shocked because I'm
thinking how the hell have they they got
this camera and then there's the story
come on and because there were so many
hangers on a holiday and they knew about
this camera and someone's stolen the
camera sold it to the press and my whole
thing was with that was that the way the
papers and the press put out there is
that these please woman they made that
that all these incidents happen in one
night which weren't because the holiday
was a week and there was footage from
all over the place and yeah they said
that these people these girls and
there's they were secretly filmed and
that it was completely nonsense with my
case I was with a girl and someone gets
the hotel key for free and they come in
from behind and as soon as we sense that
there's someone in the room I jump off
the girl and right and basically get out
of the room get over him make sure the
girl was okay got her a taxi so I didn't
secretly film or like it was being
portrayed and I think the same with the
other boys so again that was tough that
your label is listen what we were doing
and I and I put like I said we fought
were above the law and bloke say we I
thought I was above the law and bloody
blah but his certain things that I
wouldn't do and that was one and I was
getting harshly criticized for that yeah
of course but for them to say that we
secretly filmed it was it was [__] I
must have been fun Mia I loved it it's
home I like how many how many chapters
are named after women
the girl you milk before it was worth
the death yeah why not
yeah I did yeah and again when I was in
Ipswich and you're you're in the
championship and you get a level of Fame
you anything uh yeah but then when going
to Newcastle and the way I started like
for how bad the team was struggling I
started off like a house on fire
I was just ripping up that first few
months yeah and then obviously getting
introduced to what by Warren to the key
side it just I couldn't believe what it
was just like being in one of these
holiday resorts every day it's just
because the way that I understand never
been to Newcastle couple of times now
has spoken to you about it's quite a
bubble it's it's a bit like Liverpool in
that sense that it's you are the man
around town because you play for the
biggest team yeah in one in what they
believe is the greatest city in the
world you know there's all these clubs
everyone's that going out having a good
time do you think that plays into it
somewhat well it massively and one of
the big things about Newcastle again I'm
saying he got a law stick from the fans
and people saying that just because they
40 what to leave but it won't JJ when he
said it was he had to he had to leave it
was like living in a goldfish bowl and
he couldn't cope Jermaine Jean this year
and the fans were like yeah yeah but
honestly he he couldn't deal with it and
the amount of room is like you said that
about the 50-pounder but I touch on the
rumor there's a story in the book about
the gangster you probably would know the
gang I'm not gonna say that a family's
name but basically a move us yeah we're
talking about rumors so it was probably
in my first season at Newcastle Wyndham
it was big ow he pulls me aside and says
my dad pulled me the other day and
apparently you've got some gangster girl
scared some gangsters daughter pregnant
something come Wow so listen how bad I
was away ever
I could account for every girl not set
with regards against so so I kind of
dismissed it yeah whatever it's just
blue castle so later on or a couple of
days later I have Freddy Shepherd
ringing me and he's like Karen have you
heard the rumor about the gangster and
he was telling me that about this they
blow people's kneecaps off and they live
the better telling me the story saying
Connie down like now I'm like wow so I'm
still like 100 pin is [__] and cuz i
know cuz I know I slept we've all slept
with around these time periods or
whatever and then later on that day the
police from Newhart the police ring me
up talking about giving me 24-hour
surveillance this is how an rumor can
escalate outside you yeah like yeah this
is serious now so I make a few phone
calls there was big bugger if you ever
come across big tiger he used to own the
Blackpool public and Lawrence was the
driver that we all use and they knew
some people saw it like listen can you
make some inquiries than that so again
in the back couple hours late at my
phone rings this of withheld number and
I never ring without numbers but because
of what's going on it could be so so I
pick up in like a hello
and then it was the gangster in the and
he was like hello this is bloody bloody
blah and you know when like a horror
film when the camera zooms into the face
and just felt like that and I'm just
like frozen he's like the wolf of Wall
Street at this point I'm actually by the
way all the policemen in the background
with the tapping
and he's just like I've heard the rumors
my daughter has never even seen you she
doesn't even know you or anything and
I'm like fueling and then what we'll
always stick with me as well as we sit
like trust me if you ever need anything
saw it out or anyone disappearing just
find me and give me a call I saw an
album yes I've always wore okay it's
quality
Wow and then a guy in touching on that a
couple of weeks later I'm in a bar and a
key getting tapped on a show and I turn
around a sunburn I don't want to give
her any intentional thinking [__]
she kept tapping me so now I'm gonna
just about to go like do one yeah so I
turn round and she goes like that like
to say I'm the champagne right so that's
just like and there's so many rumors
what go around but that's part and
parcel of of living in Newcastle because
what you were saying was doing Newcastle
recently for me yes we had a great
little tool but also what you same was
and I think this happens in certain
cities or within certain communities is
when someone gets success sometimes
people want to bring you down especially
when they're feel like they feel like
the ones who have bought you up yeah
even I've heard that and in Newcastle to
me the stories that you always hear from
some of those players it doesn't happen
every club because you don't get that it
happens in certain clubs in London maybe
it happens sometimes with employers but
definitely happens in Newcastle you've
had it yourself with that last week's
forum on Twitter Mason used to support
money late when you're at school I'm
like let's go pick up a non ensure we
set the record straight that guy now
he's but the point is it's a city where
when you get a bit of success people can
often want to see you football team is
all we have in Newcastle really like it
but it goes against what
just a team effort Newcastle I don't
think it's a safe thing I think it's I
think it's the country in general yeah I
think I don't know our minds our
mentality is that when people are doing
well there's that hinge of jealousy or
we have to knock them down well in other
countries in America they can drive a
fry and you people like hi-5 know what a
car in that if someone drives you a guy
down in Newcastle what a prick what you
know it's just that whole mentality in
so I wouldn't label that directly at
Newcastle you when because obviously you
had so much and and some of those around
you don't have that other regular people
on the street don't have that did it cuz
jealousy from me brings me it makes me
feel a bit down like cuz I'm like do you
know how much I've got the [__]
struggle they got anything in Milan why
would you want to [__] take that away
from me like you know if and you will
have [__] mean through you'd be
[__] celebratin even with the rumours
with the money in that that used to piss
me off really bad that and certain
things the jelly like you said stories
used to get me down but then it got to
the stage where if I knew my family knew
the truth and the best people my friends
knew me around the fee everything else
was irrelevant and that's the kind of
mindset I did to get rid of that because
otherwise it would just eat and consume
you like everyone exactly you cannot so
as long as they knew and the people
around me that kind of put me in good
stead but like you said where at first
it it it it did consume you even like
with the the captain's armband and the
right-wing that I think that was one of
the worst things for your public image
particularly in Newcastle Bobby for all
we made the [__] big mistake of
letting them go in the end
will always be known as the grandfather
of them is like the grandfather in
Newcastle like and now when people look
at him they feel like the people who
betrayed them particularly are you for
refusing to play for him and that's like
a cardinal sin as a footballer what do
you think when you look back at
situation now yeah I think that I take
upon myself that I I was the main reason
why he lost his job I think I've put
some context to it but that still
doesn't make a right and also because he
gained he tried to protect me by keeping
me out of the Aston Villa the game that
we needed to win to keep his job
I begged him to play and because the
fans were on my case he wanted to
protect me by keeping me out the fire
and nine and I feel that I could have
helped win that game so that whole West
yeah
even though I put context so I I feel
that I let him down but it makes more
sense when I wrote the book or not the
full story yeah and I was like alright
well that does it doesn't make it right
though it makes it more understandable
but it's not right so there's more
another thing I touch on it as well I
had a I had a big bee in my bonnet about
I play my best football in the center so
when I play for Newcastle I played a lot
of positions so as a player it's never
your fault so when I played on the right
or the left
and I didn't have a good game and the
fans were getting on my back straight
away as a defense mechanism itself is
ask because I hate playing that position
I should be playing centrally you know
make yourself feel better that old [__]
and so straightaway when I always used
to play wide I'm always going on the
pitch and negative thinking well I can
play best in center if I give the ball
like oh it's because I'm not playing
center so you know you keep convincing
yourself so you've got convinced so so
then when the fans are on your case a
bit us because I'm not playing center
field and I could have easier listen I
was a great right winger or a great it
was just the mindset me going on to the
pitch so so we add the preseason and the
whole preseason I was playing on the
field I was playing very well and we had
this we had this car over Cup ranges and
I think it was one of the Portuguese
teams were in this one
we added st. James's Park and we play
ranges and I'm playing centerfield and
this see that season we just bought
Patrick Kluivert Nikki bar whereas
Stephen Carr James Milner so we'd
obviously finished fifth we bought some
good players to kick on we've obviously
lost Gary Speed so I'm playing really
well and it was a Rangers at halftime
and Lauren robear's signalling and that
he has to come off
so Bobby said to craig you go on the
left so Craig straightaway is literally
in tears pleading I know what's gonna
happen
the fans fingers the dream team Shearer
clover up front fingers the dream team
I've been unbelievable for you please
don't please don't do this to me please
like pleadin it's not like cried usually
where [__] off and [__] that
it's like Cleveland please I've done
unbelievable for this club plead and
plead and I can see already I'm not a
left winger please soon anyway and the
gaffers like son I know you're a threat
and he's played you know I know I know
what you're all gonna do the fans at the
mine this year a clover then another so
this is going on and on and on and then
the buzzers getting pressed for halftime
quite a referee and it's still bellies
is nearly crying like our mouths stroke
so anyway I've been thinking [__] it's
only free I said take a photo you got
any key part on the bench why don't you
bring on Nicky bar and I'll go and play
on the left some problem solved
so am gaffer's like yeah good idea so we
go for the second half I play left wing
we end up battering for end ups we score
I think I scored the last goal as well
so we come in afterwards and I think
there's gonna be some Bob what just
happened and the gaffers gaffer Oh JC's
like see Monday so I'm like okay fair
enough listen Craig's my best man I
don't want a scene of thing but I
thought it'd be something what's going
on yeah so then on the first day before
Friday before we play Middlesbrough the
team's getting handed our bibs and
bloody the dreaded bibs around your
[__] business but this time the first
team again what the first team are given
the bibs Alan's going and I'm I've got
the I've got the this was on the first
day I get the Bourbon woody comes up to
me Jonathan Woodgate and goes looks like
you're playing right wing and I'm like
piss off of like played the whole set my
field in that yet and it was true I was
playing right wing so straightaway when
they got a force about playing rolling
and then I've got bee in my bonnet of
the Craig situation well Craig says he
doesn't want to play left even though he
didn't flower refused but he's clean and
please don't play me on the good
Sumerian now I'm getting punished with
being a good Samaritan so all these
things are racing in my head so anyway
train ago I sold through the whole of
the trainer I don't even go in and have
a shower
I've spot my dummy out massive you know
go home in my training kit my gear drive
home so I ring the gaffer that night II
picked he doesn't pick up I leave her
eyes from seeing a gaffer is Kieran
my head's gone I don't want to play on
the right
other players tell you they don't want
to play there it's fine I said if you
don't think I'm good enough to play in
centerfield
hopefully I'll prove my Worth and 1/4 my
way you've just bought James Milner
he's a rowing up didn't hear nothing
from the gaffer so Wham the next day
gaffer pulls me aside that's when they
get the picture so he pulls me outside
onto his patio I no end in sight it's an
argument you could tell on cross in my
face but the gaff is like I got you
missed each time but your bureau's like
gaffer my head's gone and he was like
well you need to get your head right I'm
saying I'm telling you if I play right
wing on Saturday my head is completely
gone so there's a gray line in but
listen I'm not gonna say no I basically
said I didn't want to play so I'm the
Middlesbrough game comes and he's picked
James Milner to start and I felt a bit
of relief I'm I'm not playing but I felt
a bit of relief about it which is
strange in a world but that's weird for
me yes because I'm
play right wing than exactly but it was
just my mindset of I had this beer my
bonnet if that if I'm gonna get stick if
I'm playing a certain field now get
stick I can accept that but I I don't
know it's just the way I taught myself
in all these years is that I'm not
playing in my best I used that as an
excuse and black so anyway the game
comes on and we and we're doing well and
JJ that day was of Jemaine genus was on
fire thing that I ain't getting back in
this team because we play really well
that day and then there was about 60
minutes and Bobby's called me on he's
coming on where am i coming on right
wing so I'm fuming again that so James
didn't want to come off I come a right
wing I think I'm on the pitch I always
do a job for the team and it's about
five minutes to Garfinkel school
apparently to make us to one an hour's
coming off the pitch and now I'm
assistant manager
I'm assistant captain so getting this so
I'm trying to concentrate on football so
all these things and racing red I've
refused I'm playing right wing I'm
fuming about that now Al's come enough
to give me the armband so I'm thinking
I've got a decision to make here if this
ever comes out I know how the Georges
are especially with their arm but their
arm band and number nine is treasured
things I've been there a number of years
I know something if this story
eventually comes out and I've put the
cat down I'm after disrespecting their
Football Club unfucked
but if I don't put the armband on will
people think why and he put the armband
on so um this is all race to fool my
head what the hell do I do what the hell
do I do he's running towards you
so he's what he's walking to he's pissed
off he's coming off a fetcher climber
you know how he once goes so uh
as he's walking as he's walking towards
me the way I tried to convince myself is
that if I am the unbound to someone else
because I was sub people might think us
because he was a sub this is what I'm
trying to think because I'm this is a
game gun and I'm all I'm thinking is how
the [__] I might not get any trouble
with which is crazy so I've looked
around they're shy and is a loser the
more
your players at Newcastle so I go out to
Erin and fling the arm better Erin said
you put this on
so I'm when people say disrespected the
armband I was I was trying to protect
myself in a way and not disrespect the
new the Newcastle fans by putting it on
so after the game you should have just
put the [__] online I should tell you
the responsibility in a way there and so
it should have just put it on and
realized in the fullness of time you'd
be able to explain yourself yeah I
should have I should have been a man and
put the armband on and if it came out I
should I think it's a shame really when
I hear that story because it seems to me
like Bobbi believed that you could go on
to be a real leader and obviously you
doing that now yeah but at the time you
just went [__] ready for that exactly
I think I think even with the lower
lawar and the Christian procedures and
he said you were later found I think he
realized the potential that I had but
like you said I was just not ready to
[__] reason deliberate and this
assume that you weren't ready for I was
just too immature and again what pains
me is that so they get so I [__] up the
goal so we're to one up his end and run
down the line and I literally slip and
when I mean slip I literally go
headfirst into 40 cross acid bank scores
the equalizer something are right let me
get this right I refuse to play right
wing I've shunned the captain's armband
and of cost us a goal I know I'm a
[__] but that is pretty epic for me
there's a [__] like this so I'm Dave
Aude in the change room with regards to
I'm more demo for the gaffer and he goes
off and do the press and when he comes
back in he comes straight to me and he
goes they know and I said what you mean
he says there is some pictures of us
arguing someone from the club must have
late someone from inside the change we
must the leak that you've said you
didn't want to play on the right wing
they said I've protected you I've told
him is complete nonsense so I'm like
again everything you need to know about
Bobby is that I've let you down I've let
the club down I've let the fans down but
you're still out there protecting me
just sums the man up like so yeah so
then yeah so after all that it's an
international break I then meet up with
England where's the England plane
Wembley's up under Reconstructor first
games it's in James's Park I come and a
half time
boot out of the place I think I might
come on the left because I think Shaun
wright-phillips causes first goes on the
[Music]
[__] spoon
so as [__] as I think it was I hope he
was as good as I think he was I thought
it was dog [__] as England manager yeah
I think that's into note the only thing
I had was fen was which even though
Kevin Keegan wasn't a success as
anything as an England manager Kevin
Keegan went on for like I was bottom of
the league for Newcastle but I was
playing well I was very good in trainer
that day he picks me in the team when
you turned up with Sven you knew the
start and 11:00
regardless of who's playing well who
hasn't so on the evident and I think
that is another one of the problems with
England maybe is a bit different WA
gaffe
I think I think you proved that Rooney
but England teams are picked on not on
Form I think I was shown weave when
Jordan Henderson and Jack Wilshere had
their injury problems and before the
last tournament and everyone was making
the case for Mark Noble and Danny drink
war Danny drink award just won the
league was playing the thing
butthis Danny Jo poore as good as Jack
Wilshere Jordan Anderson I don't think
he is but was he playing better the name
of course because he was injured but
they still went unless about Bobby in
this his charisma and how he'd get you
to run through fire for immersively like
I think the best managers awesome have a
little bit about that like that about
them Morini or there's a glint in his
eye there's a bit of charisma I could be
from Bobby yeah what when I watch a
Gareth Southgate interview [__] me me
honestly the least inspirational [__]
[__] I've ever seen in my life it's not
genuinely thought like to defend Gareth
a bit like a Gary speech so when I I
talk about fear so when I play for
England I always I didn't want to make
us mistake and I think a lot of players
have this and you take the easy option
and that when Gareth was a player he
always used to pull me aside and give me
little tips and like saying Karen when I
play against you in the Premier League
wherever you're playing off the striker
off our and that you are a nightmare to
play against you're running your effuse
and doing things I don't see that with
England and I always appreciated that a
lot of all the senior players a tingling
when you're talking about the English
captain was he was like for me like a
Garry speed and I get what you're saying
with regards to his charisma rate it
doesn't it doesn't come home the water
interview no I haven't when they go what
do you drink when you're playing because
you'd surprise if you actually if you
got him here and you he opened up he for
me for me as as a player I didn't he
never got me to play how I should have
played for England because again when we
talk about the fear and again when I
play for England
I was always wide so I had that negative
thing going on to a football pitch but I
suppose it's like what we you are a
preconception of who you are and then
you watch someone on a pitch and you try
and develop an idea of who they are as a
person and it isn't that's not who they
are so it's similar with Conte at the
moment isn't it because one taste again
I think clubs
I know players get but we are so
isolated from fans where play legions
officers we cannot mingle with fans they
keep on top of everything even with the
press and I think that becomes a
separation from reality so well
separated no their fur from ever kind of
in there when I when I was when I was a
hips which as a kid a journalist could
ring me directly can have my mobile he
could text me foot but the way football
and the way football clubs are run now
players are getting further we've drawn
from fans from media and it does cut
that disconnect I do you don't get to
see the real people and like I said just
going on the jungle I for I was gonna be
the first fight it out I thought I'd be
the most hated did it you don't know
housewives and then when you just and
just by being yourself and people were
like oh he's actually not what we for
and I think I don't think you can get
away of it because it's a clubs Avenue
Ian that's the way they're run but if I
ever went into management I would try to
get my players to be a lot more open and
out there were fans and stuff definitely
what do you think of Kevin Keegan
yeah he's interesting character is named
footballs of he's better figure of fun
now in English football Denis
they just everything you everything I
fought I know of him with the interview
any and the money went down in the
interview he wears his heart on his
sleeve
yeah and the best way that sum you up is
after that England Germany game a bit
when you said when I won fan says
something to me that makes me think me
and Newcastle had done so he's walking
down the side of the pitch and fans are
giving him Powell is Keegan your [__] he
just comes into the changing room and
says thanks lads but I said I'm quitting
and you got the senior players like Tony
Adams in that like brave yeah give it
he's done that time and time again
verify one criticism of Teigen he's a
quitter
that's what we've learned from Fergie
and other great managers is the ones who
could do it for a while at certain
places that stand the test time of Bobby
and like Bobby did it for a while at a
lot of places like he wasn't just like a
one season wonder by any means with
Keegan
I thought you chatted in far too soon
both times at Newcastle that's different
characters though because actually we
only really have an appreciation for one
kind of like we appreciate that
longevity of some people but we can't
appreciate I think they expect a
Ferguson is not going to happen but yeah
to expect them do you know if a good few
season some when build something and
then leave something that's in good
stead like like Bobby did so many times
I guess I was so expect he knows when
he's not right for the role anymore you
know I agree what you say so we're the
Inc I think with the England thing it
was different because it got to the
sense that we we were struggling like
how and the fans basically had grown
tired of him or what had a change so
he's like you know but we're like you
said with the Newcastle you are on a up
not the second time but the first time
he was on this unbelievable ride like I
mean you think why why would you like a
couple of seasons away yeah from
guarantee at least the Premier League
trophy like really Aaron was sharing
Ferdinand up front
that's pretty general that's pretty good
team yeah beautifully have you heard
about the beauty thing was that
apparently you were talking to him yeah
so had you heard about that before
everyone else did as well yeah so
because a gang you want to stand up for
the young player so it's interesting to
get your point well we've we've I can
only go home because Peter was he was
part of the Kevin Keegan sad when I'm
aiming the debut and obviously when I
was a player at Newcastle was always
there and I didn't think he had a
horrible bone in his whole whole body
right so when I see these stories now
I'm not there so I'm not accusing anyone
of a liar in that but I always have that
the way the games going with the kids
and especially parents with bullying and
stuff
I always think is it kids being
oversensitive kids there's threatened to
report the parents to social services
and yeah like as the kids nor the powers
that they've got us I know my rights so
you're like so I don't want to know I
remember getting told this by you cuz
I'll use player myself like it was a
good mate of mine who said the young
lads are ticking the piss out of Peter
Beardsley like they don't treat him with
the respect he deserves
and they that's ten years ago to be
honest yes so so from an outsider
looking in and knowing the guy and being
a [__] and seeing parents come in and
complain about certain things and my
pliers only play thirty five minutes
while his players sick do you like
there's a load of this bullying and
pampering crap and I was thinking is he
just told a people a few om troops and
they've took it the wrong way
yeah so let's be honest Newcastle isn't
exactly the Fountain of Youth right now
with talent I mean bloody hell Norwich
in the last round of the FA Youth Cup I
went to watching you at some good place
if anyone can build a good user base
right well notice that can only happen
from that what I just mean for the
longest time yeah we haven't produced
that's why Paul is he built an
incredibly now all those young Liverpool
for us Europe what's your perception of
Rafa Benitez if you ever come across him
and I know you haven't played out during
the washer perception of him as a
manager in a Newcastle manager I think
he's more a Mourinho type manager than a
pet when you guys to the exciting
football he's very organized but he's an
exceptional manager you put most other
managers with the Newcastle squad they
got this season and I think it'd be part
of you like so we like so wouldn't you'd
be one adrift so when yeah he's just
speaking to the Liverpool boys in that
they they they use an amazing manager
thing I just wish he I just wish he had
some bankroll like the classroom and the
thing because I think
because who could do some because it
attracts players just because of Rafa
beanie is as well what about getting
back to the sort of storyline
RIT refused to play for Bobby Robson
poor Orson after that was sacked what
was it like when you heard about that
were you were you previa the knowledge
beforehand no I didn't it so well so I I
was left out of the team we then lose to
so we drew to Norwich the next game was
Tottenham we played Tottenham and we
lost a Tottenham thing jermain defoe
scores up I was on the bench
Jermaine genus does his hamstring so I
come on get absolutely powered which was
expected and then we the next game was
Norwich at home and I start and it's
like I've never been able to play
football I was so bad and make that
worse we're playing Norwich as well so I
had 51,000 Geordie [__] and then I had
the extra $2,000 fans blew me or
whatever so it got to the stage when we
in saying it was like a relief me not
playing a right wing at Middlesbrough I
was desperate for my board to come up I
see and please end this torture and just
before I came off the ball came and I
tried to whip one round the corner into
a strikes me and I come off my shin and
went into the crowd and then my board
come up and the whole crowd just erupted
god I was feel [__] pretty intense so
it was a night game and we drew 2-2
Craig scores two goals that came and
then I've sat in the bath so peep so we
usually night game your own by often I
sat in the bath until midnight just me
and Paul Ferris in big Derrick ray we're
still there
and they come in and offer me a beer in
there and I was just thinking I don't
know how I'm ever gonna redeem this and
like I was frustrated because even
though I didn't want to make excuses
I thought that if I told him my story
with regards to why I felt that way it
would soften the blow by for if I did
that then I'm digging craig bellamy
and there's no way I would want that so
for I just had to take all the flak so
yeah so after that Norwich game the
press we're having a field day
Bobby's got one more game Bobby's got
one more game and it was against Aston
Villa and I was in the squad and I
traveled down and JJ was fitting at that
day and he comes into my room the night
at a game and says I'm gonna leave you
about all together but my argument was
that the two games I've played since
refusing were boeuf at home there's
fifty two thousand people I don't care
how mentally strong you are if you've
got fifty to feed people you're not
going to play to your best abilities I
said the way fans are always exceptional
please let me do this for you I've
literally begged him please get four I
owe you this I swear to God I will get
you the win if I have to be a one-man
band seriously and he was like no son
I'm protect you I'm just leaving you at
the firing line and that was the day
left our hours well so I'm in the stand
watching it and we played so well that
day I think we take the lead and we end
up loose and for two and you're thinking
how do you lose but I'm upstairs and I'm
nearly in tears because I know that's
the end and I weren't there to help and
I fought that day I could have helped
because I for some reason I always
played one over in a park as well
there's a couple of grounds where you
just think why Hart Lane in Villa Park
would feel apart with my two so I
yeah the writing was on the wall and
then the news came out and then and then
the air he comes into the training
ground to to tell people and I've got a
thing with eye contact anyway from what
happens when I was a kid with the sexual
abuse but when I talk about not looking
someone in the eye like one because I
would have broke down and to just
because what a dick for letting him down
so
he was trying to reassure me it's not my
father and the vultures have been out
for a while but yeah that was a tough
day
real tough day he felt guilty about that
yeah like I said I still to this day and
I have put some context I fear Leigh if
I played against Middlesbrough on the
right wing with my head right
we went up at the bad start I'm not
saying I'm a number of world-class
player but James move on my dare and
that was the beginning of the problem
obviously come and FIF the season before
the vultures have started to sell but
it's mental no but I know it's crazy up
and helmet yeah they brought in grim
soon s [__] me well is it because now
most like we've got a younger generation
who won't remember the soonest is the
player or even the manager now all you
norm for Sky Sports now if you've only
just gotten into football that's all
five ten year what did you make of him
as a manager he comes across as a
miserable but the problem with the
problem is soon this was a game for me
personally I played that stretch of
football I had in that one season when I
won the fans back over and we went on
that tear up in the cups and then I got
injured against Lisbon unfortunately
when we were we were gonna batter them
that stretch of foot Laird was the best
Laird at Newcastle so for me he was
fantastic because I was literally scared
of him literally scared of him he also
when all this problems were coming
he helped me win the fans back over he
made me mentally stronger he also when
we talking about by the time I went to
West Ham and I start to wise and up he
was a part of that because he he pulled
me aside one says and he says he said
when he looks back over his career he
can look himself in the mirror and say
he gave up a hundred percent can you and
like that always has resonated with me
ever since this
and it took a while didn't say right I
see it yeah but the nights the nights
out started thing and so for me was
brilliant but again a bit like rude hula
I don't know what it is with all of
these great players they are they not
right so they're not great management
man manages and again yes we'd lost Gary
Speed & the whole crazy love me listen I
totally agree we've grown soon as Craig
had to go after what happened when Craig
went on TV live on TV and called his
manager a liar and like to lose but
you're gonna mess with Craig yeah Craig
and like I said it's not what a [__]
player he was on his day forest night
and when we heard Shira at his finishing
just elite-level finishing you know be
long rubber Bellamy the peace the
creativity
it was [__] I would pay money to
watch out any day in the week that was
quality Brunner Oswald he comes across
that spelling me he he can't be that
much of an [__] because you're good
me to them he's put his best foot
forward as Craig has always got a chip
on his shoulder with regards to for
himself so he's not blessed so you know
how when people talk about his pace you
think talk about his place he's not
blessed for that pace Craig was fast but
he wasn't speedy like me he worked every
day in the gym Olympic lifts he when we
talk about getting the best at your
career he did everything like for all
the yes he had nights out and I but he
was the most professional with regards
to first into training like he probably
cost him his marriage marriage football
because like on a Sunday did watch all
the Super Sunday he'd watch Italian
football what Spanish for honesty he was
I see her yeah
so everything he did was to make himself
about and he was so demanding mmm
and he's not just a surfer obsessive
even off the pitch he's he's just so
obsessive once the minds are of
everybody and that comes across like I
think in his book is the humans snarl
he calls himself he's constantly like
that so he strength is seen as he's
weakness by a lot of people with his
perception because he's not a public we
made him like before Newcastle doctor
about me nobody knew who the [__] he was
like in the Premier League when we sank
rate bother me who yeah and he seems to
forget that if we hadn't plucked him
from obscurity in my opinion and
Duncan's wrong he grabbed the chance and
he did smash it to a degree but we gave
you that chance we but you then after us
he had some good care for some clubs but
he was never at the same player he was
his best Bellamy in my opinion a new
castle so we cranked when you talk about
this perception so I meant out then if
you read the chapter when I first come
across Craig we were able switch for
Norwich so we used to play each other
and then Norwich youth teams over I need
always say you [__] your [__] [__]
thinking who is this little our first
corner the next time we came up the next
time we came across each other
it was the East Anglian Derby I'm in the
first team he's the sub for Norwich
umpire and I've played about 30 games
he's threatening in and out so there's
about five minutes to come and he's on
the touch line and he's now coming on so
as he's coming on I'm playing right back
at a time and he's looks over and says
you are [__] [__] and I'm like I'm
gonna mate I'm starting your sub
menorahs like what are you talking about
and then the next time we come across
the game was Newcastle pecan tree and I
scored one of the best gods of school
for Norwich I run from the I fight a
couple of pairs of thing and as I'm
walking back to the touch dog because
he's missed about free one-on-ones and
that he's got his hands on his hips and
he's just like shake and he's there at
me saying you lucky game people or
something
so the solution was [__] so when he
signed for us and that I was a bit
what's gonna happen in the change room
but we just
he was completely different and did the
fault one of the forwards for the book
or didn't it yeah yeah he did yeah and
while some was I think you omit this as
well and when we talk about kanji
because money was at Norwich he was like
me and him were the two main guys the
best players to cut and robbie keane at
the time they were free who I everyone
was talking about and he went to
commentary and it didn't go right for
him but at Coventry because they had a
lot of senior players he went there and
he didn't say boo to a goose
if you don't mean so as you know what
makes him tick
on the pitch he has to be demand it has
to be so he kind of went into his shell
and he says he can remember and it was
against them we played them we beat them
free no when we went top of the league
there was only four games in we went top
of the league we played them free
knowing us playing well and JC John
Carver and the gaffer musters and JC
must have said something to me also and
I turn round to JC on the bench ring
[__] off JC or so him Bella's was in the
bench with comet chin he was like what
can our young players like and then he
said when he came to Newcastle again he
was still his show and he just see how I
was with the shearers and the things
like if they'd given me banner I'd give
it back anything Oh
what I was at Norwich I can do it so
then he dropped it kind of I can still
be myself around people if you know I
mean and I think that gave him the
confidence to then be demanding because
when he's not like that he he goes with
him and so he doesn't play even with the
soonest that short period was soon as
after soon as white the strangle him rip
his head off Bella's went into his shell
and the next what did he call him a liar
for I can't remember
he called grim Souness a liar on TV
didn't he is that right so again it was
the Bellas
someone at table soon as the Bellas had
feigned injury we were playing Arsenal
and Bella's is going to be wide and one
of the lads
Bela's had feigned an injury this is a
great funny story
so the gaffe of Souness was going to
leave him out so bad and me in or
whatever and it got resolved so I don't
know if Craig said that's [__] put
it back anyway it got resolved and
sooners put Craig in the squad to go to
arsal so we went to Arsenal and Eden
names the team and the subs and Craig's
not even on the bench the grazing the
hump so obviously as the game's going on
Arsenal Jeffries being Jeff's Reeves
says the Bellas oh you're injured
because one of the first question soon
as asked his wife spraying oh he's an
injured so they said to Craig oh you're
not involved today cuz I'm not injured
so Craig straightaway no I'm not injured
so I'm the game finished sir after the
game me and Craig are sitting on the bus
and on the bus you got Sky Sports and we
watch the game Souness is getting
interviewed about the game and then they
go on to craig bellamy so they ask the
question you have said Craig's in ducrai
so and he's not injured what's happened
but what's happening so soon as to said
the story about well to tell the truth
Craig didn't want to play in a certain
position so he feigned an injury so I'm
sitting was like Craig now and Craig's
like I'm not having this Bradley but and
Craig got storms off the bus we're like
what the hell something what's he doing
now anyway so their interview finished
it was soon s and then it goes back into
the studio so the guest might be an ex
Arsenal player on that and then all of
sudden you see Richard keys on his
earpiece go sorry we've got to cut you
we now got Craig felling me alive in the
tunnel so Jeff she's got Craig and
Craig's like I didn't find no injury was
he talking about
so that's when the [__] was starting to
get the fan so then we got Regis down
there somebody then go back to Newcastle
and there's a lot of research I
shouldn't and then I said - and then the
next day
[Music]
Craig's got the sky cameras going to
ease
how this is and I'm like Craig you are
not gonna win this battle and well I
think Craig add-in listen I can't talk
for him but just from my opinion I think
Craig was loved by the Jordi's then
absolutely because what a Blair he was
for him and soonest wasn't loved so I
think that he had their fans on in that
was the end and that's again my issue
with Burmese mainly just because he said
on an interview on him when he was upon
dit then I quote Newcastle thought and
Newcastle fans think that they're up
there with the Liverpool's a Manchester
United's and I remember watching nothing
in you [__] prick like was literally
that really pissed me off [__] like
European Cup winners here we've been
relegated twice in ten years me yeah you
know I mean [__] good he seems like a
bell end to us but will let them off so
moving forward yeah that was the era of
the the lead Boyer fight which I'm me
honestly I've got pretty decent social
media following thousands of tweets ask
him what the hell happened there I was
there that day yeah right when Stevie
Taylor would let you got shot down
classic
I thought playing that that was enough
for me and I said [__] this I'm going
home right so I literally get up and I'm
like me [__] gone I've had enough
right I said the lads I'm [__] on
this it was like the end of the game
right we're down like what's a 3-1 us
three know that I'm walking down the
stairs and you know when you walk down
stairs you've got the bars and you've
got the monitors and I'm just about to
turn they've all down the next set says
I look on the telly and there's the boy
had died
punch each other I thought [__] me I'm
definitely gone I'm deaf what is going
on at this club what and yeah so so
after the right when I said this suit so
after the right-wing thing of a
situation I started to win the fans out
and I was playing brilliant football we
just got into the semi-final of the FA
Cup
we had the next leg we had the
quarter-final against Sporting Lisbon
coming up and I was on fire even in the
game we're losing free now but I think
personally [__] album for a non
playing right wing I still feel I will
do that over to him
so basically I'm right wing Bob's come
square for me to give him that because
he wants me to pass him the ball and he
just whips it into the striker but I
take a different option I think I I go
out the other side to the other senator
and he's getting frustrated again for
most qualities on the pitch he gives
home his 10% work suit heart on his
sleeve who's good players will ride by a
hundred cent and he's like painting
because that was my nickname peanut pen
[__] pass through the ball and I'm
like so I get where Samba bow I haven't
give the ball away if I gave the ball
away if I could shower on me anyway so
you got I remember with two or three
kneel down at the time so tensions are
fair it and then about five minutes
later a goatee received the ball again
get it he's come to show again again
I've passed the ball not give the ball
away he's like [__] now you [__]
never passed me the ball [__] day
they're their big [__] I'm guessing
so I'm like [__] off and he's like what
and I went so now we're I'm fresh and
that game what I said was below the belt
about things like that always said but
you don't so I've turn around and said
the reason why I don't pass you two boys
cuz you're [__] [__] right your crepe
Bellamy and as soon as I said that the
eyes just like right was like something
just switched and then we'll see it was
he about my posture he was he was yeah
he had a short fuse and he's come
walking beside me he's come walking down
to me I'm facing him now and he's
heads gone and he's like coming so first
thing I've done is grabbed internal Nick
to refrain him and never in a million
years did I think what was gonna happen
next and then he's from La Finca fro
full power and whole episode last at
five seconds but each seemed to go in
slow motion yeah because I had so many
thoughts about the incident so when he's
running the punches I'm thinking I
cannot believe he's from--
she's in front of 52,000 people what the
[__] are you doing bow this is what's
going from Akers I don't know if it was
journaling but the part I just like I
didn't even feel the punches or you must
need to get on the weights or something
good so I'm when the Adrenaline's gone
you don't feel a thing so this has
happened in he's right and I'm thinking
surely not like what the [__] and then
after three or four I think [__] this
and then I throw a haymaker miss and we
get separated so I'm pretty calm at the
time I'm not angry or anything like that
and I didn't think you could get sent
off for fighting your teammates because
there's some pressing in it I've never
really ever seen nicely obviously
everyone talks about the batty and the
so incident but no one got sent off so
when the referee comes up to me and
shows me a red card I'm thinking what
the [__] so I'm I get sent off and the
groans and then he gets it off and then
I go down the stairs and await in a
tunnel so I'm waiting in the tunnel
Froome so I'm thinking so he comes sent
off next so I said are you think you're
[__] odd now you want to fight for
this fight now so weird like ready to go
at it in the tunnel and have a proper
scrap and I'm thinking love you just
give me four punch on their theater like
I'll take you but no and Bowie -
probably bit my nose off for psych I'm
probably yes oh wow
we then sprint it to each other to get
to each other we had these two masseuse
masseuse who worked in the prison's
Lenny and pull or Lenny and join us
[__] remember and they literally write
like donkus on our shoulders you know
and your little legs is like in the air
being in like we swear the [__]
prison
right yeah so then they put me on one
side they put Bo and the other summer in
the change room and they like put sit in
the middle so it's all crap right way
we're trying to get each other like
we're never gonna get heleneandsteve and
Tiger comes out of the change room the
showers after being so nice and he so as
the game over we're like Lenny and Jon
are like telling him we've been sent off
so he buzzing because it softens the
blow for real
the [__] heat of him so we're still
angry losses stink yeah we're still
calling each other
pricks all sorts and you here to find a
whiff of go and all you it's funny
because when you hear the studs in the
tunnel you can hear uncommon but it was
just like one set of studs ringing up
the tunnel surfing and who they are and
it was boom saw a team sounds like you
wanna fight you wanna fire right now
like drama go nothing yeah I'm thinking
about yeah I'll fight him now like I
want some revenge and then all the lads
come in and that's when al comes in and
I've never seen out for all hours at
that's the most anger so ever sin and he
was like you [__] selfish pricks you
[__] like going on honesty mad but he
obviously knew because this was these
last season I think he they oh great for
a season afterwards but we're in this
we're in the Cup semi-final and he knew
we'd be suspended so he's [__] raging
I'm not listening I'm not saying this
because of a selfish thing cuz he why
don't win the effort oh yeah the hole in
his mind this is his last big choice
exactly and whatever you say about me
and Bowyer we would have made all the
team stronger hmmm
so then I didn't realize at the time so
from anger I've been gone to feel in our
[__] yeah I've let the team down again
and then obviously soonest comes in and
quite he says I'm now going outside to
the media to watch the incident if I
think I know what I've seen then I will
fight the pair of you oh here we go
so the psycho yes all I'm thinking is of
guys right anger too just like here we
go again I've let like I've won
majorities back and now I'm gonna be
back to square one
I cannot believe what is happening to me
like because everyone talks about that
incident and I still and I think it was
proven with the club not punishing me
and they tried to pull the red card I
was wrong for calling him he's [__]
[__] I get that but you never expect the
fight to break out over something like
maybe on the training pitch it happens
all the time but and all I did was hold
him from beating the crap a bit after
free ride swung a punch so so I'm just
there all I'm thinking about is I'm not
thinking about the F wakeup said before
I'm just thinking about the fans I am
[__] with the fans our gang and then
soonest is obviously watched it come
back in and then he just rips into Bo
he says [__] I'm exempt and dented
and what the [__] you doin don't know
and then Freddie comes down and I'll
never forget this as a chairman of a
football club
I love Freddie I had my bumps in that
with Freddie but and he comes down and
he says to me you should have
head-butted him he like this is your
chairman I'm thinking why is that what
he did to you how you so showed so much
refrain you should have head-butted him
[__] and they just start piling on Bo
so then I've gone from feeling sorry for
myself to feeling sorry for Bo it's
weird out with these emotions we just
try to trigger them in the wind and now
he's getting all the [__] like they were
saying he had to take us six weeks wages
you will be sacked and so I'm feeling
sorry for him now and then we get we
have to do the press conference when we
had to apologize the written statements
and I think if people google that and or
youtuber I'm nearly in tears of that
cause I just think I'm I just cannot
believe I've gone back to square one and
then the next Monday at the training
ground we had to do that fake handshakes
yet we just made even worse and but when
I was going on from that game I was
going back to it my mom was up when we
were driving back to hip switch and like
[__] I put on the radio five line
phone line and all the Jordi's are
saying they should never play for the
club again and I might have been one of
those yeah
and I'm just thinking this can only
happen to me and then to be fair by
rings me up and he apologizes and and
just says look it is my fault and I lost
the thing and we made up straight away
but what made it even worse is that when
a fan complains about some physical the
police get involved in the fleece or the
police were practically begging for me
to press charges on him and I'm never
gonna do that
I leave the guy alone he's yeah you know
for me personally I was I was probably
one of the people that was more pissed
off at Stevie Taylor that there because
he was having a shocker
well at least used to in a weird way
sure do you give a [__] like an animal
like me in him when were working on
stuff projects and that sometimes will
be [__] like arguing like hell do you
know I mean and that is part of caring
about what's happening I weird wave I
like you said that by Steven Taylor
because obviously everyone class Steven
Tyler is one of their own in the Jordy
and that's fine I I know never bought
into that I never bought into that
whatever he thought it was our John
Terry I never did I thought it was up to
the dog she met and it surprised me when
he went to America and got found out on
day one yeah even he wasn't even good
enough father [__] Buccaneers or
wherever the hell he ended up that II
Grayson I I came to whips it showed
listen I like the guy but probably
masculine I always know but I always buy
into this I think he was like he he
played on a majority look at me and to
get the fans respect and to be fair we
always just say you [__] from
Greenwich [__] Geordi like you talk
[__] this Chester and the body language
was alright yeah it's a bit like when
you first start playing football as a
kid you want to be seen as a leader but
the actual football knowledge was talked
about there at all
did you always find football quite
easier than would you you would read the
game very well in it's because to play
Senenmut fields probably won the hearts
position in a way my versatility went
against me I was left out in Euro 2000
squad when Kevin King said I don't know
what your best position is but I think
I'll tell you care if I played in every
single position asset for Center off and
goalkeeper I played right
left back right wing back left wing back
right wing left wing mid feel free mid
food to up strike up top so I think
playing all their positions and seeing
it from different angles I think it gave
me a great knowledge of the game and
like I said if I had my mind set what I
had today when I was playing on the left
of the riot or any position I would have
I would have thrived but again like I
said players it's never their fault it's
never our fault and we always look for
excuses and play it out position I
classed as a negative and use that as an
excuse for having a bad game when it's
toe bollocks at the end of the day was
it something that always came quite
naturally to you did you always find it
there football is just it's so easy you
knew ways but the ball oh you always
quite a conscious place and me to coach
him I find it weird that and again when
I was coming through the Ipswich Academy
in the hip shoots when I was a nipper at
school when coming through we were
coached we were coached on different
aspects of the game when you then go
into the first team which I think it's
really refreshing with Pep which you I'd
never really see so when you go into the
first team everything's based for the
firt for the team and getting a result
so as an individual you stop getting
individual coaching because everything
is geared for the match day you see him
to play as a silent well you just look
at the results they've had with the
autumn end days the Raheem Sterling's
these individual players are kicking on
and and it's because they it seems that
he coaches individuals as well as
footage of them with Raheem as short as
the turn and Russ so so when you say did
it come naturally it did come that too
because it's like when you get into the
first more especially at Ipswich than
that I had to learn I had to a bit have
my street smarts and learn on off the
cuff if you like I mean even with sabab
you like so Bobby the greatest manager
overplay we've but we very rarely didn't
play we used to play for 4 - when you
talk about all these tactical 4-4-2 man
I'll
keep it simple never did any coaching if
he did coaching he'd do a basic
passenger and you finger and blade the
old but that just goes to show is you
get waters so yeah
I was quite fortunate enough that I
learned off-the-cuff because we did gets
we got coached to a point and then off
you go one there one position you played
very well apparently Cheryl Tweedy haha
hey what was it like didn't and pop star
and all of that well it was always under
wraps for start so it was never out
there but like you said when you you
that I call that peak Newcastle for me
because Champions League all this money
coming in day and celebrity pop star
even even though people didn't know but
like it was more of a buzz for my
friends and people like that but canal
I'm going out of what they and they
share all and stuff like that what she
like as a person fantastic it was around
the time when there was the toilet
attendant and they said she was her face
right there was a racial attack on a
toilet attendant and it was complete and
I nonsense refer Judith if she'd
revealed that she was they knew that
kind of sauce but yeah she was she was a
great girl and like I said I finger
touching it and when so she was married
or like we we dated for a bit and then
broke up and then when they Grove in the
house story broke when I was accused of
being a rapist even though I went there
so she found my address and sent me a
thinking of you card just a little touch
like that and then when my sister went
to prison this is like five six years
later uh-huh how she got my mum's
address she got my mom's address and
sent my mum flowers just say I'm
thinking of you and just little things
like that you just think that's when you
know someone's someone's like so when
you see Evan
success years and finally look like she
found a penis it couldn't have happened
to a nicer person did them because you
speak a lot about how your experiences
of child shaped your career did do you
think your experiences as a child shaped
some of your more intimate relationships
with people with women with how do you
think how do you think it affected you
and people you were close with I never
let people in I let someone in before
and they [__] ruined me so with
friends family teammates ex-girlfriends
of mine I would never give 100% I'd
always have barriers up yeah and it's
destroyed a lot of friendships
relationships I could go on it was the
stubbornness the I want to be on my own
people especially strangers they must
have flaws and not just prick if someone
brought a stranger I didn't know I'd
like walk out the room I couldn't
because I just didn't trust him I just
wouldn't allow that to happen so um so
you could you keep your circle small
yeah I've got three best friends and
they're still my best friends today but
there's been periods where I fell out
them for a year over again pettiness and
then did you click on yes men and that
any point no no because I never let
people in really and I had free groups
of friends and then my teammates became
my friends because again a change
subject and when you talk about the brat
pack and you talk about who's that when
you say no because some people won't
know the brat pack yeah wensley stop you
kid myself you can have Craig JJ Titus
Kyle caught playing Quinn afraid
Jonathan Woodgate when he came Rahman
olu olu are given but not be in there
you sure made Jonas driving your
escalated stuff yeah and with the
spinning wheels yeah
so what a generation of car like you
guys were lucky that the Escalade that
was I only wear honey the fingers you
try park that in the guy is like yeah
it's a lettuce a lift-and-drive yeah so
flashy wheels with spinner scraping on
the concrete you have to jump out over
fear you have to write like it was you
know were looking like rappers and not
yeah exactly
but going up back to that yeah so and
I've noticed this other football clubs
when I left and even Apes which you
don't have friends at football clubs you
have colleagues right you go and play
football you might have a social night
or something but that's it you weren't
cut we are general and fret we were
genuine friends and I think while we are
I'm still friends with all these people
today so that general bond and trust
that we had when we went onto the
football pitch I think that shows again
cuz when you look at that Newcastle team
you got Shearer who wasn't at his prime
so when you look our team 1 to 11
did we have any world-class players in
our team obviously Anna Shearer was
world class but it wasn't at the time
and the success we had is incredible and
I think for the negativity the thing we
get I think a big part of that is that
we generally had a bond and care and
love for each other and I think that
showed on a football pitch do you think
it was you all had a very good
understanding on the pitch as well
because that showed as well who was the
most who's the easiest player to play
with the he's eyes you the best brain my
favorite Newcastle player the my
favorite player shot every player night
no burr Solano
yeah man with me and him had this
understanding work was just and I always
play him in my all-time 11 in everything
he was and they said if he had my pace
and if not we had pace like genuine
ridicu that he would be when you talk
world-class he would be on a different
planet because I have never seen a
football and brain and a right foot like
that and I've been with David Beckham
they had a wand but Nabi Solano's was
just he was
my favorite player by Mars and weirder
again when I first come as a young lad
in Newcastle you always used to invite
me round for dinner and it was sudden
and like when you talk about because I
talk about Newcastle phones when I
fought I kept the team up that last
season there singing a song for everyone
and they like worship CB s key and I'm
thinking [__] I sign a book like
[__] CB s just kept you out like and I
get it
but one player who's idolized by
Newcastle and rightly so he's not
because that guy was in my favorite
prior to play with ever not saying he
was the best but my favorite was just oh
my favorite my favorite that moment
there's a Newcastle fun I told you about
this yesterday weirdly enough when we
come back and beat leads 4-3 and then I
think almost the game after I will be
asked was before and then lates the song
yeah and when we beat Arsenal
we went top of the league at Christmas
and I remember being a kid thinking what
a [__] team I support what top of the
league at Christmas we'll just a rinse
Arsenal at Highbury and the pace the
creativity a good as well yeah a great
asset in the smush them we I think Titus
gave them a goal early was it's when he
does there tries to clear and it comes
off and then we break pilot gets sent
off yeah she Rose corn-based Clare he
said the red card are already coming
hard he was doing the given at the Good
Samaritan they know Andy O'Brien schools
a header row bear goes down for
apparently share of schools depend
Craig Bellamy gets sent off and then
Robair makes it free one that was that
was my police game was really one of the
best games are played for the club I did
only must have been my Aston was my
first proper game back from a long-term
injury and then to go tell him road and
we were on fire that day I think I hand
him free to gold not be schooling the
last me I was [__] with sick me
understood but yeah like you said we had
so much legs around Allen because he was
the best finish are
and then type Craig myself Robert all
these legs around him it just we just
attacked attack detect you also part of
like saying Beckham you knew this
generation of guys who arguably like
megastars and you were part of that one
thing that's been mentioned about that
Park which is a little bit as the
gamblin and all that was going on what
was how bad did it get
would you say I think the the the excess
the Euro 2004 like I said women players
I was the winner only tournament as I
remember it as a play what if he didn't
gain did Jesus but so yeah the Euro 2004
where there was when in the we're
talking about how bad the gambler was at
one stage that I was about 40 odd grown
down when we're playing free card break
we were playing free card break and it
was four or five was playing and I've
looked up like was having a peak on my
cards I see two free-for-all black
diamonds in the suits so it's got to the
stage that copper players are as free of
us left in and we're going to going to
open a time to cut open we didn't have
cash at it tight so we owe you so it's
going to going to and to go to go to go
to coaching and the and the finger free
free card brag you cannot see unless
this two player so this is going on and
going on and then I think that go by for
band Eggman so it's going round and
round loads of times so I'm now I'm
panicking so I look at my finger I've
got two free for all of the same suit I
think by them so anyway someone goes out
and if someone sees me and I was in the
hand I have four two three four three
they have like a nice two free but off
different suits so in that one hand I
went from four e-40 ground down to like
55 grand up so it was a hundred grand in
one hand and you just the most houses up
and you're thinking
listen we're all on massive wages but if
that's just one hand if Majan if you
have a bad week you could be half a
million pounds down
and you're preparing to play France in
the Euro 2000 I don't care how much
money you've got how well for you are if
you've lost half a million pounds to a
team a three days four days before a
mess how do you go into that page
playing to to your maximum if you don't
mean so what they do is they come to you
and they go you score a goal today oh
yeah that's a good way but don't ya it
doesn't work like that so when you I'm
not saying that was one of the reasons
why we didn't do well in the
tournament's but if you put that kind of
culture then the cup that the mindset of
we [__] in bags and that kind of thing
and the unprofessionalism you put that
all together is that a reason why
because for all that when you talk about
that golden generation with the 2002
2004 2006 tournament the 2002 World Cup
we lost to a team that we lost to Brazil
and Brazil had Rivaldo Ronaldinho and
Ronaldo was there from free they had car
fou and Roberto Carlos who were probably
the best full-backs the world is ever
sin they had Lucy owes a beast of a
centaur asked they bred one of the best
holding midfielders into your borough
and we lose to them and we're classed as
failures and you're thinking if we beat
them I think we go in to win that
tournament but you're talking about yes
we had world-class we had a world-class
team of world-class players but we were
mr. Steven Gerrard and Gary Neville on
that tournament and we've lost to
probably one of the best teams ever and
we're classed as failures and then you
go to two years later we are flying in
that tournament
Rooney obviously gets injured but then
we go out in penalties and as you see
the Euro 96 team what
shiron are classed as success but they
had to be Spain on penalties and Spain
scores a goal that was a legit goal
different kind of Spain if you know I
mean and so it just goes to find margins
that because we lost on penalties we you
know and that's always a lottery tale
I can't understand everyone's because we
I reckon us probably one of the only
times when you look I look at Euro 2004
team and it was Gary Neville right back
soul John Terry Senate arrives Rio was
obviously the suspended from the drug
test Ashley Cole left back Beckham
sculls Gerard and Lampard as the
midfield for and Michael Owen
arraignment and you look and you think
that is genuine 10 world-class players
and at the time so I get where everyone
says they didn't achieve what they did
but losing on penalties is such a fine
line even the great Spain team they had
to be Portugal on their way to win the
tournament on Penry's our Euro 96 team
had to be Spain to get to some so yes we
underachieved but i think the criticism
when they say they didn't perform is
maybe a bit uh SH I'm less bothered
about criticism yeah it's fine um so
what I was just gonna say did you when
you talk about the betting you talk
about it these guys are mega stars and
arguably you know you're not you're not
taking back no I don't mean when I say
that do you feel the certain pressure to
sort of keep up with these guys in a way
and prove your worth in that side
because that must have been difficult to
go into a group of guys who go like
David Beckham is sitting next to you and
you're going in as someone who's not
that you're not David you know you're
not but now you mean in a in a financial
sense and I yeah well in all ways it's
you know David Beckham is but in some of
those players are considered to be so
there were demigods in a way at that
time like did you did you feel like you
had to keep up was there that many I
think I think when you listen when you
look at the John Terry's Frank's Rios
they've all wired their scrapes they've
all done their cock-ups in the start but
they fulfilled their potential they went
on to be world-class players like you
said on the same Ages Frank and people
like that
I'm a my England debut isaac miles
headed them at the time you know has
come
for if you're not mean so when you went
to the English Quanah you see that
success they did they should have made
me realize to wise up okay now they've
done it like why aren't you fulfilling
your potential and like I said it was
only when maybe when soon is coming and
then I got the move to West and when I
had that mindset they were like an
inspiration to me that yes they have
cooked up a look at them now they're
fulfilling their potential
amazing players and it's just a shame
that I never got the chance because I
could never stay fit after that because
I I firmly believed in my prime that I
was I was well on my way to doing that I
mean I've been critically in me but you
were a [__] class player there's no
two ways about it but that brings us on
to the injuries you had a lot
unfortunately and I just want to touch
on that before that you can push why is
it like to be an injury prone player
because we say players like Daniel
storage and they almost get or they get
a lot of [__] for it as if they know
they're from you know the I think it was
really an eye-opener to my family my mom
my wife is that they get obviously they
they know about the child abuse and
that's very sad but reason about the
embarrassment and the torture injuries
caused me and because I was I never
watched show vulnerability and I never
spoke about it actually he's breeding
that for them they I think of brought
tears to their eyes because do you know
how many games I played with ripped hand
we've ripped hamstrings because I
couldn't go off to see my board going up
so I would play with ripped hamstring
and this is numerous over a handful of
times with a rip fire or rip hamstring
where I couldn't face the shame of my
board going up so I would go all the way
to halftime so I didn't have to have
that embarrassment and I have
so many times in the if people ask
people when they think you're injured
and they think I'm a he's getting paid
he's in the treatment is complete an
utter nonsense like I said the
embarrassment it causes you the pain it
causes you because all you want to do is
play football and embarrassment is the
the word that sums it up it was even
where some gold was a he took you all
What did he say I can't really remember
he basically said we have a player who's
done fuck-all for the clubs on this big
dough and it's about time they retired
but also people don't realize and it's a
great story at Newcastle I touch on in
the book and it it cost me a year of my
career but it lost Graeme Souness his
job and lost so when I done my hamstring
I come off against Sporting Lisbon and
we end up losing I get a new contraire
that season because Souness wants to
build the team around me and I missed
the hole and next season as soon as
obviously gets sacked
so I do preseason and we're in that
crappy cup then that entire crappy Cup
so we're just about to play a team and I
fill my hamstring again when I did
against Sporting Lisbon so I go for a
scan and the radio will just raise the
scan says I've got a grade one strain of
my hamstring a few weeks of rehab
anyway this goes on for the whole season
and it goes on for the whole season
I go to see I'm gonna wall fire I go see
specialist all up and down the country
one specialist and it's my back one
specialist saying this my hip anyway we
cannot get down to the bottom of thing I
miss basically like I said the whole
season I come back we play a game
against West Brom and it was the first
time soon that's got to play what he
would classes he starting 11 I come on
in second half and we had a midfield of
Nobby Scott Parker em ray me on the left
Shearer Michael on upfront which sounds
on paper funk is very decent we win the
game free meal Michael owns scores to
Gregor Shira scores a great goal
I go down the line take on someone
pulled a ball back my Cologne score I
fill my hamstring again again
embarrassed shock play the rest of the
game I go into the change room
convincing myself that it's just tight
as tight I know it's gone but you know
you getting the massage - massage it I'm
right does that feel tight and he's like
yeah yeah and I think yes convinced me
so we have sunday off we go Monday and
because like I said I'm coming back from
hamstring I'm trained and half-italian
soon this is like you need to train you
need to get match toughness
anyway I break down crying was just
saying look my hamstrings gone and I go
into the I go into the change room and
at the time I was taking a medication
for this like condition I had and the
medication slows down your healing
process so they were trying to say that
might be a factor for Maine juries which
it wasn't but at a time the club then
issues a statement saying Kirin won't be
out in the unforeseeable future because
a medical reason which was the worst
thing you can do at Newcastle because
then the rumor rezar that I had cancer I
had AIDS
I had [__] people ringing me up are
you dying and all these two reservists
are sitting there thinking so yeah so
you thinking what the hell so I'm it
gets to the stage now where we play as
soon as he's under pressure and I'm
doing more rehab Moorea go and see all
these specials all up and down the world
all for a hamstring and all the Keystone
is a great one M Street so as soon as we
play a man sit away and I'm in the squad
and I'm having a fitness day on the day
of the game and I could feel my
hamstring but again bit will do a Bobby
situation where I want to play against
Aston Villa I say even though Miami's I
want to play I will try my hardest to
get you this win and he's like thanks to
the gesture but no he loses he gets
sacked
so you're thinking I haven't played all
season soon as was gonna build the team
around me haven't helped us I'm a bit
low so Glen Road he comes in and at this
stage I'm finger on retirements and Glen
Road is trying to persuade me to
- am stay idem play against self Hampton
in the cup and I scored the winner I
pulled my hamstring again that same
stamp feeling after five minutes I play
the whole game and score because I'm so
embarrassed of coming off is that
constant pain constant pain every strike
every stride I had it's like you get the
stab of fear in the night but it just
mentally I just had to get through it
so I'm was just making it worse
ironically surely well I'll get to what
when we find out so so again I don't
tell no one score the winner we play
chow and a few days later and then I'm
like I can't go through this pain no
more I said to Glenn Roeder that's it
I'm done battled because remember the
physio so what I'm getting to is the
radiologist who's reading my scans are
the ones who and I'll get so the physios
are like they're just devastate for me
they're just like that's why we everyone
was going about the medication is it
slowing down you hear Linda dadada so
Glenn Roeder is like I'm sorry I'm done
news like QM I know you've been through
please can you go and see John Green I'm
like who the [__] John Green it's like
ease our Western physio Eddie's got his
own clinic so I said all right so I went
down to this John Green and he's clinic
was an absolute [__] all right
like equipment from the eighteen
hundred's they look like so I'm already
soaked and so and he slips me down to my
boxers and he's just assessing me in
what was a good thing straightaway he
assessed that my right glute was it
wasn't firing so I said what does that
mean he says try and tension bum cheek
and I couldn't tense up my right side so
he said that's a good sign because when
you're sprinting that your glutes mean
to kick in to take some of the strain
off your hamstring so all your
hamstrings doing all your work software
honest that's a sign at least we're
getting somewhere so he said have you
got your scans so I've got a year of
scans from my hamstring so I said yeah
so he said let's go down to Jerry Healey
he's one of these but work someone in
these London hospitals
I can't believe what I'm gonna say Nick
so we go to London we get these scans on
he puts all of these scans on the on the
thing and he turns on the light and he
goes oh you got para tendinitis
literally so for them from the scam when
I first did it in pre-season toured the
scans every single one he got asked para
tendinitis so I said what does that mean
he says basically you've got a para
tendinitis is the tendon in your
hamstring when you run because you're
gross not kicking in could you run your
putting strain on the tendon it's just
it's inflamed so the muscles not taking
on you of the soil yes so it's just
inflamed so you just flare up your
hamstring and that's where you get the
stabbing pain so I was like okay I said
so when they're saying you've got grade
one ripsi zone no you haven't they've
read those scans wrong so I said okay so
when you hear parroting the nights you
think I need an operation or it's gonna
be and I said so what's the cure then he
says well I'm gonna now take you and
give you a steroid injection let the
steroid Jackson set we was tendon down
and then you're good to go
so as a so I had to process this so I
said if I'd have come to you at the
start of the season when with that first
scan you would have said you've got
parent tendinitis you were to give me
the the the injection I would had then
go on with John Green and just built up
my glute for a few weeks
and then I wasn't benefit for the whole
season so I lost the year of trust and
medical people to do know yeah it was
the the radiologist who was reading them
those who is if you go to hospital for a
scan radio it's got nothing to do a new
cast was the hospital's so we lost the
year soon as lost his job I'm getting
labeled linden injury program it yes it
did I have injuries a lot yes one that
one thing could have been prevented and
you just think could you play the whole
year okay
the next season when I came back the
season when I said I kept him up I
played every game I played lie about 40
games and I came back into the season
you think and you're the one we're the
one who gets painted in this brush of
always engine that and just something
that simple could have unreal I'm reduce
so you must have a certain
those people who were reporting men this
person's injury the conative remember
his name so no no I mean the people who
are reporting the journalists oh yeah
this guy's injury poem how do you but
they just see the effect they don't see
the cause they must be like oh because
you what I'm saying is you they can see
that effect that they're wrongly
attributing that effect to you rather
than other people over the
responsibility I do yeah I did because
again I've touched on it I think when I
live my life professionally when I live
my life right I can never stay fit I
think it goes some of that goes to the
lifestyle that I was living regards to
out four times a week and living wrong
and my diet was crap but there are times
especially like you said where as
football players you put your trust into
these medical people and it's a medical
people own humans but they get it wrong
and you do everything you're told we
have regards to rehab and when you keep
breaking down you're the one who gets
labeled as thing when really you've just
got the wrong advice and that was proven
that I missed the whole year of my
career and even with my broken leg at
with them which I go into great details
yes I had a horrific injury double like
a double but it it should take was a
pretty straightforward operation I had
four operations on my one leg [__] me
for operations where and I go into it in
massive dinner one God to go what what
did you think about him at that point
all like because you know really said
that it was before
well you hungry or what did you just
think let it go I was I did laugh to
myself because the amount of times I say
to his physios these Western physios is
it time for me to check it in and they
were like no no no and I was like well
if you really knew that I was thinking
about it numerous times then I don't
know why you have to come out but he
just bought a club and I was asked on
that West some funds like I'm too much
no I was just I was just like you're the
owner the club you can say what you want
there's a great trick actually those
sorts of people you go I would take one
Laxus was very definitely in a bag with
him so when you see someone like Daniel
Sturridge now or you see any of those
players are going through chronic injury
a time like that what's how do you
relate to them because I felt very sorry
for Daniel I do
glad you do feel sorry for him because
again people classic like he's not
really but I hear a lot he's not
bothered he there was the time what was
the thing they said he hasn't got the
heart cuz did when clock first come in
he said no one's a hundred percent every
game and he's got a play for these aches
and pains and I'm like yeah it's true oh
no one feels a hundred percent I get
that but I'm I know what he's going
through and it is complete embarrassment
and how he came off after free miss the
other night I wouldn't have been able to
I would have stayed on and I think it
might get to the stage where because
it's horrible and and it's not just him
as so many players that they're at
Darren and it was before me and all
these players are of course is the call
of Tom on didn't that was thing you must
feel that element of responsibility
which that makes it even harder to
recover you got stress do you think you
carry quite a lot of stress no yeah no
like I play with the vets from a we play
in a vets League and I I'm still fasting
I've never had any problems since and
which is again quite ironic but I I do
feel with my injuries because of the
type of getting like I said I was always
in the top free running and I broke into
the first team I had a hundred games by
the time I was 18 I mean I just think
it's no coincidence the likes of myself
Michael Michael oh and Jonathan Woodgate
who was wrap it as well these high
intensity players who have played so
much for a young age it it catches on to
you it was under ed after the great
scent of our England people always
mention like Ferdinand Campbell and John
Terry I always fought would get was the
best of the four of them actually but I
design iris I I put Rio first and in
would he say and
now just just in order if you would he
was like he would be in training yeah we
did used to remember at the age
wow I thought I was quick and yeah he
put the Bunsen burners on me once and
left me like wow and I was I hope I
could go like where some players are
rapid over 10 15 yards I can maintain
that over 102 and aegis he was yeah it
was a great lad he was but he was a
weird one to work him am Lauren robear
lauren robear was I love Lauren Robair
but Lauren robear was so Timberman or if
you shouted at him he will refuse to
pass to you and again right
I swear so if you Baalak Tim or that
like could you imagine Craig he went
like two games without passing to Craig
and like Craig would have a tap in and
he would shoot from a ridiculous angle
and he and Craig would liners [__] in
that and Lauren was just like down to
him like but his goal was the one that
was used in the movie call Lauren
Newcastle fans said to me that I didn't
score a great amount of goals but I was
a squirrel a score of great goals yeah
for new cutter that somebody got to
school but then for Lauren's just like
one of those when they were just well
yeah yeah I just want us one more thing
fast we final question what are you like
as a dad because it seems like you've
grown up a lot and you said used to be
quite hard on your son and I thought I
when everyone talks about my book and
obviously the abuse chapters in it I
always say the hardest the hardest
chapter for me to read is the daughter
chapter and I touch on about when I get
a girl pregnant my daughter we decide to
keep her a secret for for four years and
I said I fell out with this girl and I
went a year without seeing my daughter
and I touch on about the first few years
of my oldest son Kai obviously was in
Ipswich and when I had days off oh it's
an IO and Julie's I was a night of
question you Ferrari and like why wasn't
I going home and every day so crushes
Ferrari on the tone bridge yeah so I'm
saying like for the first three years of
my oldest son and like I said I lost a
year my daughter's life I basically say
that I played at being a dad for a bit
of money at home for your doing your job
but I was a [__] dad if you know I mean
that's tough to say and tough to hear so
I'm yeah now I've I think I'm a
fantastic before before you came today
by the way I read that chapter upstairs
in the kitchen yeah literally like I'm
about to meet you yeah and I had this
image of me hadn't I thought alright
he's actually he's definitely lonesome
disguise and you are I knew before I
said alot you that you're not the person
I thought you were going to be just by
reading that that she cause it's harder
of course especially as men you are
judged more than anything on how you are
as a dad I think yeah of course yeah how
do you think it's been for your family
to read the book because I I've been
closed down years of yeah you have been
abused and spoken to their mothers
and some of those mothers felt a very
personal responsibility some of their
parents felt very personal
responsibility how do you things been
for your family to read how your life
has panned out so when I gave them my
mum the book and she then text me and
just said that it's the she said I cried
for her and that was the saddest thing
I've ever read so I'm like I was a bit
confused because yes the abuse bit sad
and the the daughter chapters
hard-hitting and I was like and she was
like no the whole book because because I
was so bravado clothes didn't speak to
anyone even with the injuries even with
the Grove in the house accusing the rape
and how they tortured me and these are
the people closest to me and they'd they
fought I was fine before I was coping
and I mean when really I was
internalizing yeah so for your mum to
read there and not know she was like and
that's the same with my wife so it's
really hard for them really hard to read
her and it's not just like you said this
the books not about just abuse there's
so many layers to the book and reading
the whole thing in and just me being
honest brutally honest because you don't
really hear people being brutally honest
and basically suspect got away and he's
saying like even the iron Apple I'm not
saying I'm a prick and for them to this
is like I said when I was going to do a
book I said I want to do it right and I
think just from seeing their reaction
and I've had just Craig de Geste Bernie
JJ people close to me were friends were
not family reading there and they just
like respect you 100% I'll tell you one
thing you can't sue me you have another
boring life Lee yeah when I was talking
about it and you say every chapter is a
bit like wow well well and people I I
she's trying to sell books so I'm not I
love I think you can voucher to skim
over and [__] me out like
chapter 15
it is one of those four as worth reading
and if you want to buy it I'm gonna put
the link in the description below as
well so anyone can just click on this
video and buy it right now and he's well
worth we recommend it there's a lot of
guys that we have on this show well
we've had a few people on the show where
I've thought you've had a very sad life
but you still that maybe a face out some
of the stuff that's happened yeah and
some people try and book old tent on
their story by you haven't paid your
solid the best slide or anything you've
just caught I would share really I
imagine I was incredibly sore relieving
experience as well just sort of being
able to tell your story and almost tell
the truth in a way rather than wrap it
up in something else
yeah again when this book was coming up
become about about four and a half years
ago was in the make and we we we started
doing it and then I went into the jungle
and then they got put in the back shelf
and then we start up again and I always
say we like people say about Craig's
book and everyone's like are some
amazing book and Oliver Holt read his
book and wrote my book can you sign and
credit when I was like mmm Politico
correct you know I mean it's a it's a
good book that's not the real crude you
mean yeah that kind of thing that cuz a
lot of players do their books while
they're still playing so they've got to
be a certain way you've got employees
and stuff and I think I was fortunate
that I haven't got no toys yes I'm I am
employed by Ipswich as a coach but as I
said to the the people who employ me I
said look this book is educated every
sixteen-year-old who is out a football
club should take home a copy of my book
and this is the dangers of what happens
with wealth fame and if like you said
that puts these people what happens and
if I go into because someone's been on
to me about Fink Joey Barnes doing a
book launch up and down the country like
a sit down I think it's called the
no-nonsense store and would I be
interested in - I've had some management
company and I said I'd rather go in to
have Academy kids 16 you're assuming you
kids and sit and talk to him like this
in a way art Ellen I think that would be
more beneficial and it gives a great
purpose of why these books out there
well the last question I've got for you
man yeah how would you like to be
remembered Wow didn't know how don't
prep for that yeah Alan said the same
thing yeah I'll ask it everyone so I
think it gives them a good a good idea
of who you really are if you put out
what you would like people to say about
you I would like to be remembered as
someone that learned from their mistakes
and bad their selves as a human being
but we've talked about a lot of
underachievement and I think I mentioned
this before and when you look at my
ability and talent I had did I under in
my career I did but again what I were
injured as a kid and dealt with that all
on my own to play one minute a football
professional football I think is this
assists success and so I have mixed
emotions about my career but to overcome
what I did and make a career is
brilliant in itself but on the other end
I should have I should have been
mentioned with some of the better
players of this country but again like I
said I've learned from my mistakes and I
hope just you like having me for two
hours people can see that I am generally
okay of a good time machine thank you
cheers pal thanks for you Cheers
last one once again if you want to get
Kieran's book links in the description
below
hope you enjoyed the video if you have
hit the thumbs up stay subscribed thanks
for watching we'll see you later